Sweet baby jesus,
we're back again.
Somebody had tweeted me,
I'm going to say sweet baby Jesus.
You shouldn't say that.
If you don't believe it to that man,
I say,
fuck you dummy.
Dare you.
How dare you for your own self.
Don't put that down in print.
Asked some people talk.
Some people before he say some shit like that.
I say merry Christmas to motherfucker.
I think I believe in Santa Claus.
Settle the fuck down this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast brought to
you by stamps.com if you have any sort of a small business,
we have to send shit out of your house.
Um,
and you know what a pain in the ass it is to go to the post office,
get everything laid out and all that crap.
You can eliminate all that with stamps.com if you've heard this podcast before,
but now you're like,
motherfucker,
do you have to say this the same way every time?
And the answer to that is yes.
Uh,
the code word is jre do that.
And you get this $110 bonus offer that includes a free digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
There's a little right hand corner of the upper right hand corner of stamps.com
is a little microphone like old schooling microphone like Lenny Bruce used to
use.
Click on that bitch and it'll ask you if you,
uh,
have a coupon or whatever code and type jre that's you want to type and you'll
save some money.
It's an excellent service.
It's what Brian uses to send out all those desk squad tee shirts that he makes.
That's all right.
And by the way,
there's a new one that's on the way.
This is my favorite.
The new one is my name.
It's cool.
It's,
it's dope.
It's very trippy.
A death squad.
Dot TV.
So all those a t shirts,
that's all Brian's creation.
He makes those all himself.
So,
um,
if you,
uh,
are interested in them,
they're on up.
There's a presale form right now.
Yeah,
just go shop squad.tv.
Actually all these will be sent out with stamps.com and he's been using
stamps.com for a long time.
It's a great service for you,
right?
Yeah,
it's great.
There's no way that I would do this by taking all these packages to the post
office and just trying to sit there and have this old lady way every single one
of them and do you know,
and then we're going to be old lady.
It could be a dude with a gun.
True.
I mean what young kids are like,
Hey,
I'm going to get a job at the post office.
Who does that?
No one does that
blend.
It's a post office.
A good job,
man.
That's the,
any,
any sort of government job like that.
There's,
there's a lot of benefits to it.
It's tough to get fired.
It's on the way out there.
Right.
Um,
you know,
when I think,
I think that we're going to have three d printers and we're going to be able to
make things in our homes.
I think they're going to be shipping raw materials to us.
That's what I think is going to happen.
I think we're going to have like raw materials in our house.
Then we're going to download the instructions or the code or whatever the,
the,
the bin file that's going to lead to like a computer and you're going to print
up a computer in your house.
That's what I think.
I think they're going to have the new code.
You're going to get the new code.
I mean eventually.
What would be amazing if they could ever figure this out and I know they've
considered this is recycling your computer,
taking
the raw minerals out of and reprocessing it and using it to make a new computer
like that.
They're going to get to a point where they can extract minerals from,
from used up electronics and like recycled them.
Absolutely.
Completely.
Like everyone at home,
you know?
That's what I think the future is.
So you'll be using stamps.com to send cold tran right through the,
through the mail.
What that stuff's called cold cold.
Can we started?
I don't know when I'm allowed to talk to is you're allowed to talk anytime.
This is very,
just wait,
I'm sorry.
We'll get through it.
Fedex though than like ups are ever going to take over the mail,
the US mail or like a company that you send your mail to that will then filter
all that bullshit and then it's sent to you like one letter every two weeks that
you really need.
Hmm.
I Dunno man.
I mean you wouldn't want anybody filter in your shit because what one person
would,
you know,
if someone can like arbitrarily decide what kind of mail you shouldn't,
shouldn't get,
then they get like boycott companies from sending you like legitimate mail.
Like there could be like problems with that.
I don't think that would be suggested.
I think that the model that is uses ups though.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh I didn't know that.
To ship things like they make deals like go rent space.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But um,
anyway,
easiest way to do it.
stamps.com use the code word,
You get this $110 offer.
It's pretty sweet.
We're also brought to you by legal zoom.com and legal zoom is a website that is
essentially set up to do a lot of legal shit for you that you would normally
have to go to a lawyer and pay a lot of money for.
They can sort of guide you through,
uh,
things like incorporating,
forming an LLC.
I'm writing a legal will.
They can do all that shit online where you don't have to go to a lawyer and
spend an ass load of cash and if you get in over your head,
they'll actually connect you with an independent attorney.
So if you're like,
I don't feel comfortable with us anymore than you can get connected with an
independent attorney and uh,
they'll,
if you need any additional guidance and if you check out legal zoom.com and see
how they can help you out,
it's not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your specific direction.
It's kind of an interesting setup.
Um,
use the codeword Rogan in the referral box and you can save yourself some money
on that as well.
In the past 12 years,
like 2 million people have used legal zoom.
Then you use it.
I used it.
How easy is it?
To be honest,
it's so easy.
It's almost too easy.
Really like tricky.
Do you get no,
I mean I unfortunately I didn't use all the information available@legalzoom.com
to figure out how what I was getting myself into.
You didn't,
you asked that was drunk and I was just like how I hired a guy hired,
I mean I got a girl off the internet to come to me.
I didn't even remember doing it the next day and then I was like,
wow,
that was easy.
Yeah,
I'm a corporation now.
Wow,
so you became a corporation while drunk.
Yeah.
That's pretty sweet.
That's legendary.
That's legend Shit.
And it's done through legal zoom and looking.
I wouldn't recommend that.
No,
that's not a story.
Like this is the,
this is how I approach,
this is how I approach operated.
So you could hire the girl.
No,
no,
no.
Contact with this person from legal zoom and they,
oh no,
no.
What I was comparing it to is how easy it was.
Like when I,
this other thing I did when I was drunk where I had flown somebody out that I
barely knew from a different country to stay with me for seven days.
A couple of weeks ago.
It was just like that where the next morning I did didn't,
I woke up and I was like,
holy cow,
I did all of this.
Wow.
That was easy I guess and it it,
you know what's though they send,
they send you this really nice like book and you have like a stamp with your
corporation name on it.
You know for I guess doing paperwork which you're supposed to do when we have a
corporation and things like that.
You have like all this good stuff that you're supposed to,
I mean it's a really nice package but just,
just be careful with what you do because this is serious shit.
This is not like,
Hey,
I want to do this and that.
Like really use all the information that's available@legalzoom.com to figure out
what you're,
you're,
you're doing,
because it is a,
you know,
there's some things on there that's,
adult stuff.
That little shit.
Yeah.
It was like kids like me,
drunk,
blacked out shinning.
I've gotten them themselves.
That is kind of weird that you can do illegal shit online while you're hammered,
but how do you know,
how do you stop that?
Can I have like a USB thing that you plug in?
You have to suck on and it gives you a breathalyzer and then it's like,
bitch,
you can't put that online.
You know?
It's almost like the idea that you could just go and do some legal shit while
really hammered out of your mind.
That's terrifying and it has ramifications and all kinds of tons of those.
Yeah.
So don't drink and go to legal zoom.com that's sound advice from Brian Red
Redman.
You know,
you've got to learn from people's mistakes and Brian's willing to let you get a
little peek in his life.
Your Guinea pig.
Yeah.
There you go,
folks.
He did that for you.
He's like,
Jesus,
he suffered for you.
The son of Mary.
Yeah,
sorry.
As legal zoom.com.
So a go and go fuck yourself.
I also brought to you by audit.com.
That's o,
n n I t.
We have the new gorilla kettle bell that's coming out any day now.
Um,
if you go to,
uh,
on it.com,
this is ridiculous.
Ford slash.
APPS.
Ford.
Slash.
Gorilla.
Yeah.
No one could make that an easier.
They have like,
um,
there's a,
a,
a package like you can win a uh,
um,
an on it.
Primal Bell.
I don't know how you win,
but you can enter and a,
I guess we'll give him one.
It's their,
it's their super bad ass look and these gorilla ones,
I can't wait until they come out.
It's a 72 pound one and it looks like,
can you see it?
There is angry face gorilla,
right?
Yeah.
Send my Twitter somewhere.
But uh,
that's the,
the second in the line of primal bells.
Their kettlebells design like evil fucking primates as a chimpanzee and a
gorilla and the gorilla one is so bad ass cause the chimpanzee,
I always think of the chimpanzee has the face that a chimp makes when it's
biting your Dick off.
That's this.
But this,
this gorilla,
this is the face that a gorilla makes when it's hovering over you and it's about
to take your soul.
That's what it looks like.
The gorilla is amazing.
The guy who did the artwork for the grill,
it's so bad ass.
And I seriously,
I look at these things that I could work out with a chimpanzee when I actually
imagine a chimp trying to kill me and it gives him like an extra rush work
workout thing about gorillas and chimpanzees.
Every you go,
it's like,
you know,
we were going to go find the man size chimps.
Fuck that dude.
Good luck with all that thing I'm going to think about could good luck.
I would never go near those fun things.
They're just so gangster there.
They're smart and they're strong.
It's fuck.
And if they decide to go after you,
you gotta like you gotta real problem.
You can't fight off at chimp.
They're smart.
They like bite your fingers off first or voted by Boone.
I wouldn't fight those either.
You don't want a Fang?
Yeah,
I just think,
I think we are so ridiculously week the human animal,
like even the strongest amongst us,
the most bad ass football player of all time.
It's so incredibly weak compared to a real prime.
It would win between Ray Lewis in the baboons about Boone.
Maybe Ray Lewis could like hurt it real bad,
break a leg slamming on the ground or something.
But what if he gets bitten a neck?
You know,
if it just locks on his neck and puts his legs around his fucking shoulders and
start sucking his blood.
Woo.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
Right.
I don't know how you'd fare there.
Uh,
I,
I think humans are just weak as fuck.
I think even when you see a guy like ray Lewis who's unbelievably strong for a
person like bitch,
between the a person like my size and a person his size,
he's not even the same human like he can do things to people.
You've seen that guy ragdoll giant men just whacked all them with ferocity.
A chimp would eat his ass.
It would hold him down and eat his ass.
It would be no way to stop it.
If a gorilla decided to fuck him,
it would fuck him until he starved to death.
It would just hold him by the neck and just girls have a little tiny dicks.
They only have like one inch Dick.
I did not know.
They're small.
They don't have to have big dicks because they dominate.
They doesn't matter to them.
It feels good no matter what size it is and the smaller ones don't get bitten is
easy.
Isn't the,
isn't the gorilla the one where the Alpha gorilla gets to have sex with all the
yes.
Email and everybody else is trying to kill him all.
Yes,
so that they can screw them.
Yeah.
Their,
their appearance is entirely for protecting themselves against other gorillas.
And I guess other,
you know,
other like predators,
but like they have these giant fangs but they eat grass.
They like Broccoli and Shit,
you know,
and they have these like a huge arm,
all the ridiculously strong.
I'd like.
There are hundreds and hundreds of pounds of fury.
Why do they freak you out so much?
Because he,
I don't think we can even imagine the horsepower that something like that could
generate if it was coming after you.
I think,
uh,
I think it's,
if it didn't exist.
Okay.
I think the problem with chimps and gorillas is that exists and that they've
always existed.
So we look at them and go,
Oh yep,
there's a champ that's a gorilla if that,
if you didn't know that was real.
Okay.
And there was this black hairy thing that's sort of like a person but not really
and is obviously aware that it's locked in a cage and it's fucking,
it's like 600 pounds of muscle and it's looking at you and if it got a hold of
you here,
are you a part of like tissue paper?
He couldn't do anything.
You have no options.
You have zero options.
What would you play?
Dead.
Would you let it kill you?
Let it kill you.
What'd you run?
You can try to come up with a stick or a rock that you throw into its eye or
something.
If you get really lucky,
you could hurt it and scare it off enough so you can run away if you get really
lucky.
But if you don't,
if you throw that rocket,
it hits him and bounces off like it's been at a styrofoam but like the uh,
a bear.
You're supposed to play dead or you know the shark is with the punches and know
what are you supposed to do with a gorilla?
What's the I suppose to stand your ground?
The stand your ground?
Yeah.
I don't think you're supposed to make eye contact,
but you're supposed to stand your ground so that when they make a bluff charge,
which they always do,
you can't respond.
Right.
If you respond,
if you back up,
you are fucked.
He just keeps coming up.
They'll just smash you.
If you,
if the respond,
they'll smash you,
but they,
if they run up to you and you can handle it,
apparently they don't want to fight.
They just want you to get the fuck away from them.
Right,
right,
right.
Like most of the time,
guerrillas aren't looking to fight people.
They're just like,
bitch,
you better get the fuck away from here.
Right.
And then they'll charge up to you.
We'll look,
bitch,
I'm not fucking serious.
And then you,
what do you do?
You've gotta just,
you gotta just get the fuck out of there.
Nice and slow and,
but don't,
don't run.
Don't run and stand your ground.
It's a terrifying prospect.
If it happens next time in Africa,
and I'm going to go,
I hope Rogan is right because,
yeah,
I hope I'm right too.
I like standing there.
He's still coming.
He's still coming,
Joe.
The grill is like,
why do you,
why did you do I really want to run on big chewy scared of me.
Yeah.
Um,
there's,
they just fucking,
they freaked me out.
Primates,
primates freak me out.
They all freaked me out.
A monkey killed a dude in India last year because I met like a mayor or some
town and a monkey killed him.
A bunch of monkeys.
They jumped him.
Fuck this dude up.
Monk is good people,
man.
Sure.
Fucking terrifying.
Anyway,
on it.com oh and,
and I t check out the new gorilla,
a kettle bell,
which comes out very soon and we've got all kinds of other shit too.
Of course.
News report of this lady that,
uh,
and this is just going on around the Internet of what to do if a bear comes.
Oh No.
The funniest shit ever.
Listen to this.
Okay.
Her face.
What is she
don't run away.
Oh,
she's acting like don't make eye contact.
Oh God.
Hold on.
We'll curl up into a ball.
She threw a shoe at it.
Yeah.
They said she was not going to worrying flat.
I wouldn't throw my,
I think you shouldn't lay flat,
would you have to curl up in a fetal position and put your hands over the back
of your head?
What you really got to worry about as I'm Severin arteries than biting into your
neck.
You've got to put your hands over the back of your neck.
But good luck,
bitch.
That's a 900 pound dog,
900 hundred wild dog that kills Moose.
We had a big face attack.
One of our crews once it was in Alaska in the High Mo,
uh,
refugees.
Oh,
I'd love that story.
Hold on.
Let's kill the music man.
Let's begin.
The official podcast is,
that's one of my favorite stories.
Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
That special that you guys did,
the Arctic Adventure Heimos Arctic adventure.
Yeah.
That was the first thing that I found.
That's how I found out about you guys.
Oh,
I watched that.
I watched it twice in a row because it was so fascinating.
First of all,
that there's this guy who was not a dumb guy.
No,
he was a smart guy and he was very,
like very articulate and really passionate about the way he was living his life
in this really harmonious way.
Hunting and gathering middle.
Yeah.
With a log shack and his wife and I believe at the time he was the most romantic
remote person on earth.
That's why we did it.
It's incredible.
It's a,
it was such a fascinating thing.
This guy hadn't ever seen the towers fall.
Yeah.
I mean the most iconic shit and the,
the history of this country.
And he had never seen that.
He had just heard of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was so remote and so self reliant and it utterly fascinating.
Really fascinating.
Uh,
so,
and the been so heartbreaking to,
and who's talking about losing his child?
The,
the,
the canoe tipped over and they lost their baby.
I mean,
dude,
it was,
oh my God,
it was so,
so heartbreaking.
But what's so fascinating is really,
it's like into the wild.
If the guy was an idiot.
Yes.
If the guy actually knew what he was doing,
I think that into the wild guy.
I mean,
I,
I need to really look at the story better because all I know is the movie.
I saw the movie and I believe that the movie doesn't represent the truth.
For whatever reason,
they decided to make it out that he'd eaten some poison.
Right.
But it wasn't really poison.
He just starved to death.
Right.
You didn't know what he was doing.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that's a shitty thing to do.
Yeah.
I think that's a shitty thing to do to make a movie and put this artificial
ending to a semi historical event.
I mean,
he's,
he's like a sort of a poetic figure.
This guy who just goes off into the woods and yeah.
You know,
becomes this,
you should know maybe a bit more about it.
I mean,
how about something about it?
He didn't know anything they were high,
was like,
he can just live in the middle of nowhere.
Yeah.
And,
and just
live never gets warm.
First of all,
he doesn't need,
he doesn't need a refrigerator.
He's hanging this Caribou on the sticks outside of his house when the scene is
so crazy because this dude has always food hanging from frozen slabs on these
trees and then bears come around and he has to kill the bear.
I mean it is fucking bananas.
Just thinking about that is the bear was tracking the team.
So they left to go shooting and went off and the bear was tracking them.
It was hunting them and so everyone was,
was aware of it.
And then jaimal goes,
oh yeah,
by the way,
we're being tracked.
Like he was totally new it.
He understood it.
He goes,
and if,
if the bear comes in,
comes tonight,
it's going to come tonight.
And if it does,
then we're gonna have to shoot it because otherwise it's going to get us cheese.
So sadly they had the shooter.
Sadly my ass,
that's I'm fucking giant monster.
Once you eat people,
I fucking get crazy when people go,
you know what's really fucked up?
Those people shouldn't have been there in the first place.
Sure.
But they were okay,
but they were a team people.
Okay.
But they were,
the guy had of course they had to shoot that fucking bear.
What are you just going to move?
You're going to move now?
Well I mean,
and he lives there and it was actually tracking him because I guess you know,
got some of the meat from before.
But uh,
yeah,
we,
they,
they brought it back.
It's in our office.
The head,
no,
the,
the skin,
the body,
the toxins.
They taxidermy.
Oh yeah.
They have to,
when you shoot one,
don't you have to process the skull in some way?
Don't you have to like send it to uh,
the uh,
fishing game?
No idea.
I think that was like one of the things that was said was that it's a,
when you,
when you shoot a bear,
and I should get my shit straight on this,
but I think there's something along those lines.
Could be shaving herself defense.
You have to send the skull somewhere.
Thought Hi.
Moe had a deal that deal with that wasn't there one of,
wasn't that part of it.
Right.
Maybe I'm confusing my bear things.
I've always been fascinated by barriers.
No,
I don't know if you saw it,
but we went to another,
now the most promote person on earth is this,
uh,
I don't know if you heard what they live in Siberia and the mountains and they
were like a Russian Orthodox during the revolution and they took off during the
revolution and they're still there.
Well,
there's one now.
She's like 85.
She was the youngest and uh,
she lives there in the middle of nowhere on this mountain in like this crazy
sawed place with light and they didn't have shoes.
I'm like,
how do you,
how do your feet not freeze?
That's incredible.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
They don't have shoes.
Yeah.
How cold is it?
Fucking go home and no shirts.
Yeah,
no frostbite.
I got it.
I
got to watch it again.
But it was,
they were,
it was going on about no shoes.
Now they have shoes and now they have like,
they wrap their shitting furs and stuff,
but when they first went there,
they didn't have shoes.
And you're like,
how could you not have shoes?
They must have wrapped it in something or maybe they stayed in during the
winter.
It's so fucking crazy.
Barefoot in Siberia.
Yeah,
you can Google it.
It's,
it's a totally insane story.
That was like five of them living on this mountain in the middle of nowhere with
nothing.
They had nothing had zero.
That's his thing too.
They're like,
they're almost like,
like just super evolved monkeys.
Yeah.
You know,
they're like,
well,
it's interesting because I was like,
if you actually take away everything,
like there's no matches.
Like,
you know,
you maybe you had matches the first five years of the first year,
the first five ABMers but like 80 years later there's no,
they don't have matches.
You don't have,
you know,
glass,
you don't have,
you don't have anything.
So to go back to really primal,
like we have nothing shit,
but you know that there's another world out there.
It's not like,
oh,
I don't know anything.
Like they,
when they went,
it was like the twenties or thirties so they had like cars and shit while owns.
Wow.
So how did they get by?
What would the,
how are they cooking their food?
Well,
the first,
it was like the first decade they were just eating like roots and they were
starving in the winter and they couldn't get buried.
And then by the end they were like 65 and just running through the forest,
like catching animals by hand and stuff.
And you're like 65 years old.
I mean they were sort of super cut and tough,
but they got an animal's by hand.
Yeah,
well they had snares and they'd run them into like traps and stuff.
But uh,
but then the,
they were really religious,
but then there was some weird sex shit that was going down.
I forget horse going on down there,
but if you leave a bunch of people by themselves that's fucking each other in
very weird ways.
Once they realized no one's looking,
once he realized that there's no one else but them,
how many people were that were up there?
It wasn't a lot.
It was like,
it was a family and they had like two or three girls,
I believe.
And then there was the parents and then like uncle Peter wanted to lie with Jean
Chesca or whatever and Oh my God,
you know Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
If you only have a small group like that,
it's going to be a mass.
It gets,
it gets,
it gets lord of the flies quick.
Yeah.
What is it about humans?
It's so disappointing.
Like consistently pretty interesting.
If you strip away like cops and artifice and modernity and technology,
we just go eat quickly very quickly.
We go ape shit really quickly here.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just,
as I get older,
especially the broad spectrum of our ability,
whether it's to be just utter complete cunt,
merciless,
killer,
Gingiss con style,
it's like super nice philanthropists person.
Like the broad spectrum of what people are capable of it.
It hurts your brain cause it's,
there's,
there's so much conflict going on and there's so much weirdness and the,
the potentials for human behavior and what it's all based on,
like the,
the principles of thinking and the,
the,
the feeling of comradery you're supposed to have with your community and
extending that to people that you haven't met before and don't disregard them
because the numbers are so high that you're overwhelmed with people that you say
you lose a sense of community.
I was reading this book,
uh,
and I,
and I saw
words I didn't know.
So I googled it and they were like,
it's this empire just before the Byzantine Empire.
And uh,
and then I just sort of went down the Wikipedia page and they're like,
and it's this empire and then this emperor kill December.
And then took his wife and then they married somebody else in another empire to
save it.
But then they ended up,
you know,
going and your reading going,
this is fucking game of Thrones.
Like they were just,
they were just kingdoms all fully killing each other,
trying to marry.
And then they would have a kid and then the kid would come up and slaughtered
the person who slaughtered his dad.
And it was just like,
but,
and,
and the,
the way that they killed them,
the way that they deal.
So it's fascinating because you're like,
oh,
that's human history.
We just went after each other like continually,
you know,
for thousands of years until we decided let's does a weird thing that we have
with like extreme levels of competition too.
You know,
I was watching,
um,
some rugby the other day.
I had never seen rugby before.
I mean,
I've seen it.
I've seen like,
you know,
a guy has a ball and he's got running.
I didn't know what the fucking rules where I had no idea
fueled TV the other day and it never seen it before.
And all of a sudden I'm watching this savage fucking game,
like the best.
I love it.
So first of all,
it's so aggressive.
They don't rest.
Like in football there's all this resting going on rugby,
there's no continued.
Like that ball goes down,
then something's happening.
I don't understand the rules.
I don't know what the fuck's going on,
but I just know some dudes are colliding into some dudes and their restaurant
over shit and it gets pretty fucking savage.
The only sport I think that's heavier.
Well there's two is a Australian rules football.
Fuck the fuck out of me.
Literally kick each other like they'll just yet.
Uh,
and then uh,
what the garlic,
like a hurling like gala.
Yes.
When they have sticks and they watch shit.
I didn't even know about that shit until dom Irrera school beyond that stuff is
crazy with that,
that ax handle that they're carrying around a whipping it shit.
What a fucking nutty game man.
We have this need for that extreme release and I think that's what what sports
are trying to do with things like,
you know,
mimics battle,
mimic more does it mimics bowel mimics war n it alleviates the need to engage in
those activities.
You can vicariously engage in explosive athletic,
aggressive activities without getting your body destroyed,
without having to go to war,
without having to harm people around you and be in a constant state of war.
It's almost like we figured out a way to sort of calm the monkey down a little
bit.
Give the little monkeys fake violence.
What's the quote?
Business is the modern form of art.
Modern Art Barn.
Formal warfare.
That's,
it's just like going after each other.
Like we're going to get them put coke,
Pepsi now you know,
and you're,
you know,
all these generals getting their troops lined up.
Sports.
I like the training wheels of enlightenment really.
Cause they're allowing people to go through the need for war and conquest
without actually going to cross crossed the line.
We still go to war.
The word,
the really weird conflict that comes out of sports is when sports fans fight
because they like opposite teams and you're like Jesus Christ boy,
he's really,
you're fighting.
Cause this guy likes the red team.
Woody,
are you in a year?
And the crap shoot and the bloods,
football hooligans.
Oh my God.
Do you ever want to read an amazing book?
It's called among the thugs and it's this literary editor who goes and lives
among the Manchester United.
Oh my God.
Paul from and they go around and just beat the crap and they have like just
crazy,
like crazy fighting techniques and stuff and uh,
they,
you know,
then they'll go like,
oh,
we fly into you Ventas,
you know,
and there's 85,000 Italian fans.
Oh my God,
5,000 of us.
And we're like,
okay,
that's cool.
That's having,
and you're like,
you guys are fucking nuts is insane.
5,000 dudes try to took on how they do it all the time.
Yeah.
It's so crazy.
What a bunch of savages.
Yeah,
they have that old school savage gene that goes way back to like fucking Henry
the eighth days and they're fighting dragons and Robin hoods and shit.
You know,
like English people have like a different set of genetics.
It's like there's a warrior,
like a history of the war.
They like our,
our genetics are all confused locally.
Like they get over here,
you know,
our genetics,
like start here.
Of course I know this is not how genetics really work as Mike Theory.
They get here and they're like,
nothing [inaudible] going on here.
No one's really attacking us that much.
And like everybody calm the fuck down.
But in Ireland and England there's still remembering why they drive in the left
side.
They drive in the left side over there so they could sword you with the right.
That's what it's for.
That's where their strong side it.
So if the guys come and you want to be able to hack at him with a sword,
that's some crazy genetics man.
Yeah.
The English I think learned the best that whoever wins is the last guy standing.
So the,
the,
their whole thing is like,
you know,
Italians or French,
whatever sort of say,
yeah,
I've got a few licks and you know what we'll get,
I'm going to go get sewn up and come back and then this guy will just stay,
keep staying on the field.
But I'm not leaving.
I'm not getting off of here,
you know?
Yeah.
What a crazy history.
You know when you,
when you go back to like European history and the go back to the revolutionary
war and just think that was only a few hundred years ago.
The,
the like the British are coming,
the British are coming like the red coats.
That was a few hundred years ago.
That's so recent.
As you get older you realize how recent that is.
Like when I,
yeah,
when I was a child and I would tell,
you know,
someone would talk about like the,
17 hundreds cause I lived in,
I was in San Francisco in [inaudible] 76 I remember it was a spirit of
70661776200 years.
And it seemed to me to be so long ago.
It was so long ago.
But now that,
that is like 40 years ago now I lo I go,
oh that's not that long at all.
Like we've only been here for 200 years.
That's not,
that's a tiny little little blip of time.
It's nothing.
It's,
it's a weird thing when you really start to consider how long people have been
around and then how far we've come.
Like as just as it's cumulative,
like it gets faster and faster and faster without a doubt.
Right.
The amount of people that you meet that are tuned in to what the fuck is going
on,
right.
That jumps every year.
Every year you meet more people that are tuned in.
Do you know who you talking to?
Someone in the middle of talking to him,
you're like,
oh,
okay,
this conversation is only going to a certain place.
You know,
this guy,
there's a roadblock there and you know,
he's telling me how,
you know,
whatever he is Peskov Alien,
a Mormon,
whatever it is,
whatever,
whatever foot strict Republican,
there's a wall that you hit.
The earth is less and less of that I think.
Sure.
Well I think,
you know,
if you look at,
I would think it about this too,
because if you look at history,
we're sort of like,
yeah,
we had some spears,
you know,
we had some bows and arrows.
Oh it was a sword.
And then were different,
better spears and better bows and arrows and all across bow.
And it sort of went like that for like,
you know,
recorded history and then you hit the 19 hundreds and just goes goodbye.
You know,
claims spaceships,
fucking lasers.
You know,
like a nukes.
Oh yeah,
we can go up a whole continent now.
You,
we can blow up the whole world if we want.
You know,
it just went,
in reality there was a lot.
Okay.
Then the first half of the century,
but the last half of the century,
like from let's say the forties on like what the fuck?
Like the whole world changed the whole world.
Every fucking thing.
Oh,
there's the moon.
Let's fly to it.
Yeah.
If I can go boom,
you know,
and,
and uh,
you know,
now like going to Mars and you know all this shit and you're like,
what the fuck?
Like
pulse from Mars with a robot.
It's insane.
They shot a robots for the air,
landed it on another planet that's all in Dothan.
I'll just like a million fucking miles away.
I just wonder like,
it's like a million miles or 10 million miles or whatever it is.
What do they have?
Do they have like a Sega Genesis control pad?
Like how do they control that pocket?
But it's 1 million mark.
How can you,
how can you,
how can,
even if it's going by Lightspeed,
which is the fastest shit can go,
it's still got to take like a year to get there for it to move the robot.
How does that work?
Probably using like gps coordinates,
you know,
it's probably not actual video or anything like that.
It's probably using like,
like a GE,
we didn't like satellite or something like radar radar.
Satellite would only work if you're underneath it.
The fastest you can do it is lightspeed and lightspeed just to get to Mars would
take like a little closest approach.
Mars is as close as this 34.8 million miles.
Oh my God.
That makes me scared.
I get so scared when people talk about like going to Mars.
I really like legitimately
start shitting my pants.
Just thinking what if they sent you out there?
What did they put you on that tube and shot you to Mars?
I saw that.
Uh,
which one finger?
Schwartzenegger.
Oh,
he went to Mars.
No,
no,
I saw the sports there.
Was that total recall?
Yeah.
No,
but I'm talking about just being in space in a tube for six months.
No hurling through the galaxy with no safety net.
No.
She'd see the Dick pic of on Mars that they took.
They took pictures of Dicks.
Oh yeah.
So the rover drove it,
drove it down.
The one that the planet,
they just found which one?
The one that reigns glass.
Jesus Christ.
450,000 mile an hour winds or something like that.
Something crazy like that,
right?
Yeah.
It rains glass.
That's like almost as bad as the shark shark.
Oh,
I can't believe that was a real movie.
You would have to have like diamonds closing sharp NATO.
Sounds like it'd be a fun movie if I'm moving to me.
Oh No.
But they made it my ass.
I bet it's fun.
Yeah.
I like stupid moves like that.
I love that.
A Parata movie.
We've talked about shark NATO a long time ago before you even came out for some
reason.
Did we?
I forgot.
Remember it.
There wasn't no,
he's also,
I'd like the octopus that had,
instead of legs,
I had sharks as legs.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
That's so stupid.
And yet awesome.
Um,
so yeah,
this planet rains glass.
It's 4.8 billion kilometers away,
so it's almost three miles.
Three,
3 billion miles away.
How reigns class?
That's crazy.
The fuck man.
Jesus.
It's blue.
It's a beautiful blue and it's raining glass.
It's like a spinning gigantic,
like one of those little paper weights.
It was glass paper waste.
It looked bad ass.
How easy is it to sneak somebody out of the Philippines?
There's enough to do with rain and glass.
Settle down son.
Right?
Uh,
it's not,
it's not hard to seek anyone out anywhere.
You got to get a passport,
which are remarkably easily.
What about visa?
They have to get visas to leave,
so no one's gonna you game.
He can't like download a wife.
I can't do that.
They'll get you what they say.
She,
she says,
I have to act like I'm engaged to wear it,
but then they have to go through like you're going to get scammed.
I go through emails.
Giant brothers,
they're going to hold you down.
Take your money.
They're going to be say,
he'll be like,
these guys are sleeping at my house.
I'm not really sure what I should do.
I'm thinking to call him the cop,
but I don't want the girl to leave.
You're good.
I didn't know.
Was that hard?
Yeah,
it's hard,
man.
So yeah.
Planet rains glass.
Well,
yes,
but uh,
we were talking about like the second half of the last century.
Yeah.
I get these because I'm a,
I'm a history buff.
I get these texts.
It's an amazing thing.
It's an Oxford professor who,
uh,
who sort of puts into like a tweet tweets.
So I'm now getting the tweets from 1941.
Like,
what's going on in that account?
I don't know.
I gotta take my phone.
Yeah,
tell me what that is.
Awesome.
I got to tell you,
it is awesome because you're sitting there and you're having a weird day.
You're having a hard day.
Let me just see.
I got money from there,
but you're,
you know,
you're like,
ah,
fuck today sucks or whatever.
And then you're like,
oh,
500,000 Russians were captured,
you know,
outside small Lens.
Here we go.
World War tweets from 1941 it's a World War II.
It's called at realtime ww two at real time.
Wwt Nazi plans for all of Russia up to year olds because to become a German
fiefdom full of disarmed slaves goring,
we can drop bombs on them in case of riots and you're sitting there going,
these are all like news headlines and shit and you're like,
this was just what you read in the news every day you woke up,
you got your coffee and you're like goring says we can drop bombs on them.
In case of riots were just going to have work pens and people are like,
oh yeah and then now I'm going to go to work and do the shit.
But if you,
if you read the tweets it's like what the fuck was going on?
Just like what you were saying,
1776 what was going on in 1941 when like people are still alive.
A lot of people are still alive who were there at that time and you sit there
and go,
Holy Shit.
Like,
we were doing some fucked up shit one generation ago,
like fucked up shit.
And uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Hitler and his chief ministers are now in secret meetings to discuss cutting up
the cake of Russia to dominate,
administer and exploited.
They're just like,
yeah,
we'll have Russia now.
We're just going to take it over and fucking,
and you're like,
what the fuck?
I was only 1942.
And you're like,
what the fuck were they thinking?
What the,
what humanity was so fucked up or is so fucked up?
Yeah.
I don't think we've changed so much in one generation.
That's the whole thing.
I'd say again,
I mean maybe I'm beans like super optimistic about this and I get accused of
that all the time and I,
well,
being optimistic is go well.
I don't understand people's,
um,
the,
the people resist that,
you know,
because like what evidence is there?
I think there's a trend.
I think
that trend is the trend,
this,
this information trend and this growth trend with human beings.
I think it's a,
it's an honesty trend and it's a,
um,
it's a,
it's,
it's a trend where people are realizing that instead of like just seeking out
people and being an asshole and just being a Dickhead,
you can be nice and you can also realize that there's some repercussions to a
lot of shit that happens in this world and that you can use your money to
protest and you can talk about things and like this Trayvon Martin thing is a
perfect example of this I think because there's a lot of people that are very
upset with,
with,
with how the verdict went down,
but there's so little violence.
Sure.
Some people are saying,
well
there's some,
they're pointing at a few things in this guy got hit in that guy got hit and
somebody did through some rocks or something.
That's going to happen in small,
in small numbers.
That's going to happen.
Exactly when you consider the amount of people that are,
that are out there that are upset and how little violence is actually being
actually enacting.
There's,
it's a,
it's a very strange town.
I agree with you.
And I,
I think it's a couple of things.
I think one,
if you ever go to really violent like place where they have super violent
reactions to things,
there's not a lot of,
uh,
movement of information.
There's not a lot of like,
you know,
a lot of the most dangerous places of the most illiterate places.
If you go to Afghanistan,
he goes to Somalia,
they don't have literacy,
they don't have movement of information.
So it's just word of mouth.
It's like that guy,
you'd have to kill that guy.
He's a wizard.
Yeah.
Or he hates you or whatever the hell.
And so I think that now that there's,
we're bombarded with so much information at all time and it doesn't matter,
you know,
if it could be on TV,
it could be on your phone,
it could be wherever.
And because of that,
it's,
it's actually bred a lot more tolerance.
Cause they're like,
that guy is a wizard.
The wants to kill you.
And they're actually like,
no,
he's not right.
He's just a dude over there and he,
you know,
he doesn't have any water or whatever the fuck it is.
And I think that that movement of information has led to us being able to
curtail our lunacy to go back to 1941 and say,
just,
you know,
a generation ago,
we were like,
yeah,
everyone's going to kill everybody,
you know?
And,
and now we would say,
why the fuck would we do that?
That's stupid.
We're not exactly,
hopefully,
oh no,
I do think you're right.
And I think it's that,
that ability to share information that everybody sort of gets a piece of what it
really is instead of that's the enemy and they're coming,
holy shit.
Yeah.
It'll be up on Twitter now going,
no,
that's bullshit actually.
Yeah.
They don't want to bomb you.
Actually,
the people of Iran don't hate the people of America.
It's one fucking dude who wants to do this fucking bullshit.
And you know,
that's the whole thing that I think that,
you know,
we have to get technology and the easy consumption of technology out to
everybody quickly.
I think it's,
it's the most important thing for,
for spreading information that's ever existed.
You know?
And sure it's beneficial for everybody,
including the people in power,
like the idea that it's beneficial for democracy.
I don't know about for people in power because people in power to do some shady
fuck yeah,
they do,
but they got to cut that shit out and the only way they're going to have their
only way they're ever going to turn that shit down is if it all gets exposed.
Which is why you know fucking,
you know,
snowed and shit like that.
Like those guys have to keep doing that.
If by the way,
if you work for the CIA,
sorry,
Cia Keller,
you guys tell us all the stuff.
We want to know it all.
I'm sure he's doing really good work.
I'm convinced mostly the CIA does excellent work,
so thank you very much.
Thank you for your service.
I think that a [inaudible] man,
this is my point is that you can have a government and you can have senators and
congressmen.
You can vote all,
I was a bit do it the right way.
It can be done,
but it isn't
being done across the board uniformly.
Even if you don't want to cry conspiracy.
Just the way it's structured is absolutely ridiculous.
The way that these people are allowed to contribute it just vast amount of money
to campaigns.
That is insanity.
That's bribery.
I love it though.
I'm like,
look,
I'll tell you one thing.
Seriously.
If I can donate 1.5 million to Republicans or Democrats,
I don't give a fuck who it is,
but if I can,
if I can get the American Ambassadorship,
I'm not even an American,
but if I can get it to England where I live in a castle,
I ride a white horse and put on,
you know,
princely robes and I can get that for 1.5 million or Rome,
be the guy in Rome for five years.
That's awesome.
Right?
Especially if you're like some Donald Trump baller.
Dude,
I know it's happened to all,
it's not Obama just above.
It's all of them.
Like they all do it,
but I'm just like,
how?
How amazing is that to be in and just be like,
you know what?
I want to be the fucking ambassador to Rangoon.
No,
I want to be the ambassador to India.
I want to be the ambassador to India and get dressed up like fucking,
you know,
like a Roger and I'm going to only come and I want tigers and and,
and you know,
like it's a million and a half bucks.
What the fuck?
Sure.
I'll pay a million and a half bucks if I can be the ambassador to China.
Maybe that's a big one.
Maybe we wouldn't get bored after a while man.
First of all,
you get really tired of fun.
You get really tired of the assassination attempts because they be trying to
kill you every day.
Somewhere like England where it's just like,
you know,
you just start wearing a wig and then you start powdering your face and like
putting like,
you know,
weird,
you know like people 17,
seven no,
no,
like seven like dress like little by little you dress more and more like 17th
century dudes,
you know?
And then you're like,
what are you doing?
I am the ambassador to England and I just think that'd be awesome just to be
able to say that I think would get,
it sounds like something really good on paper.
We'd have to do lots of get,
it'd be like lots of terrible like okay the,
you know,
Ladies Horticultural Club of the Midlands is here for your,
tea and crumpets and you're like,
I don't want to get out of bed.
I don't think it would be,
it would also be like with my luck it would be like we'd be attacked,
you know,
like urgent toi would attack us immediately.
Did a week for her and then I'd be like,
I dunno.
Fuck guys,
I'm sorry.
I went out last night.
There was a rave.
You guys like raving.
I Dunno.
Like it would be terrible.
Yeah.
You don't want any kind of position like that man.
Stick like doing that magazine about sneakers.
It's funny that that's what you guys started out.
You guys do these like radical documentary pieces about dude's living in the
most remote parts of the world.
And you started out like talking about sneakers.
Well,
you started out as a fucking taekwondo dude.
I mean,
then you became a comedian and then the fucking UFC.
He fucking,
I did the hardest shit first doing taekwondo.
We did the hardest shit first.
Skate shoes are hard,
man.
There's only so many types of shoes that are any good.
Oh,
it,
listen,
I gotta tell you like if,
unless you're Bob Dylan,
you know,
going electric and like I have all the focus were like,
fuck you,
you fucking sell out.
Right?
And then like,
they're like,
oh,
we're not them.
Somebody else said,
oh,
this fucking music is way better.
I think.
Unless you're going to reinvent yourself all the time,
then why do it?
I know magazine,
I know that after five years I knew how to do magazine.
Okay,
let's do something else.
And if you don't want to do different,
she's like,
I was thinking about you.
I'm like,
okay,
hold on a second.
He sort of a,
a,
a weird,
uh,
you know,
psycho a sport,
a comedian,
intellectual political duty,
stretching it out
and then you go,
oh,
I see.
No,
you're a fucking intellectual.
You Cock sucker.
You know,
that's absolutely not true.
It's totally true.
Because what do you do you come up with,
will you come up with theories and you come up with
philosophies based on my,
in my mind,
I'm sorry.
I'm thinking,
thinking Harvard.
Yes.
And my mind,
intellect scholar.
I'm thinking of the real,
a really intelligent person.
I'm a curious person who happens to be a comedian and I have a contact with a
lot of people.
I have contact with a lot of people through Twitter contact with a lot of people
through this.
And it's,
for me,
I feel like it's a,
an obligation if there's ideas that you have or if you've read something that's
fascinating or if you want to convey that you have an obligation to,
that's an intellectual.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
It sounds grandiose.
It's,
uh,
it's,
for me it's a,
it's an obligation to,
uh,
explore these certain ideas and to teach,
to tell people.
We're not saying it's a bad thing.
What I was trying to say is there's five or six
these things in there.
And it's the same thing.
Like when you,
as you grow,
you want to keep,
don't,
it's too pretentious word.
Sorry,
I can't accept it.
Uh,
just what it is is we all are human curious human to label us.
Like this is an intellectual,
this is it.
We're all curious humans.
And if you're afraid of gorillas and intellectual,
I didn't know that.
I'm not afraid of intellectuals.
I'm not afraid of calling someone an intellectual,
but I would never allow someone to consider me one.
Okay.
I withdraw the defense.
Thank you for great Ross.
I really appreciate that.
That's a lot of pressure on me to stoner Douche bag is way easier to carry.
She comes with low expectations.
Most 50% of what you talk about is,
this is an interesting thing to think about.
What does this mean?
Where does it take us?
Sorry.
Intellectual.
How dare you.
Okay.
We you,
you're pretentious definitions.
But um,
the um,
I mean the,
the,
the world we live in now in now allows so many more bits of information to hit
your mind.
There's so many more things to discuss.
Yeah.
It's like if you just paying attention,
you become an intellectual.
Yeah.
It's like if you're really listening to all the,
the,
the information that's coming back and forth between us to understanding what's
going on with the systems,
the rest
of the world with our own biological systems,
with what's healthy and what's bad and what's good,
what's wrong,
and what we've been telling you for 20 years,
it turns out to be total bullshit.
All that stuff.
Is that common Addison?
A million mile.
Even the dumb people are smarter than the dumb people in the 1940s 100% the
dopiest motherfuckers on this planet would run circles around the dummies in the
1940s so I just think,
I think we're,
it's happening too fast for us to truly appreciate it,
but I think we're in the middle of one of the greatest ages of information and
expansion of the human,
the by far.
And we're in the middle of a wave and we can't even,
we can't realize we're in the middle of it cause it's two banana.
It's also a lot of it is super important and a lot of it is bullshit.
So like the way a lot of it is,
I am I,
why am I drinking?
Intellectuals only use the word intellectual.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm sorry.
No,
I was want,
no,
now I don't remember what Dario talking nonsense,
which is,
I apologize.
It's my fault.
Absolutely.
I said how high rise,
I don't know.
We were talking about how yes,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
The interesting because it used to be there were genuinely,
you know,
a couple TV channels,
a couple of,
you know,
newspapers,
like there weren't a lot of things and now you can get it from everywhere.
And I think that is what you were getting at before.
It's just,
it's,
I think it's good for everyone.
It's good for democracy that,
you know,
one,
one or two or three sort of information areas versus 10 million or a hundred
million.
Cause you can get it from everywhere.
The problem is,
is you don't know.
And we'll look back in retrospect and we'll say,
okay,
you know,
Snowden was a big thing or it wasn't,
or you know,
whoever would like,
wikileaks was a big thing.
It wasn't,
but you know,
that's the whole thing is you were deluged with so much information on Twitter
for example.
Half of it's fucking,
you know,
people making bull shit and saying shit.
And then,
but the other half is like actually people saying some really great shit.
People say a lot of great shit on Twitter.
I hear really smart points from a lot of people and there's a lot of people that
I've communicated with on Twitter that have sent me hip to a la shit.
The amount of links that you get every day of amazing shit that people are just
like,
you know what?
You gotta do this,
you got to do a story on this.
You've got to do a story on this.
We're doing a story now and Russia,
which I'd never heard about genetic passports.
Have you heard about this?
So what have you heard about it?
No,
but you're freaking me out.
What's the genetic passport?
Oh Dude.
So we got my toes across.
Well,
it's interesting.
You're all right.
But we,
it's interesting cause we got this,
this hookup to Twitter and what it is,
is they,
the,
the Russians actually the Sylvia,
it's to go back to our 1941 Karma conversation after a World War II,
there's a cold war and they were,
uh,
experimenting with atomic bombs on people,
like not on like buildings and shit.
And like we did here in Nevada,
but on people.
So there's this area of cosmic Stein with about 300,000,
400,000 people that were,
they just over the years I experimented with on,
with radiation,
with actually blowing up bombs near them.
A lot of them died,
a lot of them didn't die.
And they,
what they had is they had genetic mutations,
so they became mutants.
Like it's like x men type shit.
So they become mutants in this area and they're actually not allowed to leave
the area and all this shit.
But anyways,
they start passing on a corrupt DNA strains,
uh,
to their offspring.
So they're the,
it gets worse as they go.
Oh No.
And so now what they're trying to do to stop it is to have genetic passports
where they're not allowed to reproduce.
They're not allowed to do this.
And so it's like,
it's,
it literally is the modern x man.
It's fucking the mutans versus,
and so,
uh,
it's this whole cover up,
this whole thing and we're going over there now,
uh,
shooting it.
We,
we have a couple of whistle blowers,
but like
that's the type of shooting.
Are we talking here?
Well,
is that allowed to say anymore?
And My,
my,
my commute and phobia and my immune phobic,
they're,
they,
they are,
they are there
technically human mutans like genetic mutations that you have to have a,
uh,
genetic passport.
And,
and by the way,
this brings up a lot of philosophical,
philosophical questions.
Not Intellectual questions,
philosophical questions,
but because you have a generic password,
you're saying,
okay,
you can now can't reproduce.
You now can like interact.
You can now can't leave this area.
You can't do whatever because we made you radioactive.
And you're like,
well,
hold on a second.
I didn't fucking ask to be remade radioactive and I can't reproduce now and
whatever.
And like it's,
it's,
it's actually a map.
Civ.
They're not allowed to soft news.
No,
no,
no.
They're not allowed.
That's the genetic passport.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They want to stop the mutant strains.
This is all true by the way.
This is the fastest is all true.
It's fascinating idea.
Now what,
when you say Mutant,
like do they exhibit any sort of special powers?
I can't believe I'm asking you this.
Kmart,
Bell,
Art Bell,
Lee.
Uh,
the majority of mutations are and,
and much like in gentleman with the animals,
it's like enlarge livers,
you know,
massive spleens um,
elephant Titus of the balls.
Like it's never anything,
by the way,
all respect to art bell.
I'm saying that as a fan.
I'm a huge art bell fan.
It's been,
uh,
art bell fan forever.
So when I say I just became art bell,
obviously I'm choking.
That guy's awesome man.
He's a,
apparently he's going to do radio again.
I used to come home from the comedy store every night listening to coast to
coast with art bell.
You ever watched it?
He listened to that show.
I have listened to it.
I know our bell.
Yeah.
It's still the best.
Who's the best?
Who?
Can I ask you a question that I always to ask you this
and I'm wanting to ask you this for three times.
Whenever the fuck has been.
Who's your favorite comedian ever?
I always say Sam Kennison for one year.
I had mark Marin on yesterday and Marin who uh,
was 21 during Kinnisons Hay day and actually lived with Kinison.
I mean he was in the Crest Hill House.
There was partying with them and do them below with Kennison like incomplete
craziness.
The story was absolutely fantastic.
I was in my glory.
So if I had to say like who is the best,
I say Kennison for 12 months,
I think it's Kennison for 12 months,
which were like 86 [inaudible] 87 was the greatest comedian of all time and we
all pale in the shadows.
But Richard Pryor was the most influential.
Sure.
There's like,
but Lenny Bruce had exists for Richard Pride to exist.
You know,
it's like the,
there was like a whole series of guys and you can't minimalize each guy's
impact.
So if someone says,
who's your favorite comedian?
I said,
Lenny Bruce.
And the reason why is because Lenny Bruce was the guy who did it.
He was the guy who opened up the doors,
went to jail,
you know,
one on stage and did this whole bit about,
we have to,
if you say nigger enough times,
like eventually it's not gonna mean anything and it won't hurt some small,
you know,
black child's feelings.
He had this whole bit about,
this is an incredibly powerful philosophical bit about the,
the nature of a hate words,
the power that they give,
you know,
if you don't use them,
if you don't use them all the time,
if it become rare,
you know what I mean?
It's a brilliant point and it's a brilliant objective point.
And then you stop and thanks to this guy did this and like 1950 something,
but he didn't,
he was on another Lego at all the legal shit that happens.
It's horrible.
And what happened even after that is more horrible because he stopped being
funny.
He stopped being philosophical and he would go on stage with his legal notes and
read out of them and you know,
they'd go,
come on dirty Lenny.
They just call him dirty Lenny.
You know like people wanted him to talk about sex,
they wanted him to talk about blowjobs.
It's just like unheard of stuff.
But if you,
unfortunately in the Commons is a weird thing,
whereas it's really,
it gets dated,
you know,
like music does not get dated as badly as comedy does.
And it's hard to listen to like a Lenny Bruce like album and understand the
impact it would have had back then.
Like I still think it's amusing.
I sense some of his points are hilarious.
He had this joke about homosexuals,
he's like a,
he goes,
oh,
being a homosexual is illegal.
Dig.
So what do they do?
They they taking,
they put me in jail.
The bunch of guys want to have sex with you.
Okay.
Was like,
it was like,
it was almost like a Mitch Hedberg before his time,
you know?
I mean there's some of it that's very funny,
but it's so dated that the,
the,
the references are so dated,
the concepts are dated,
but Kennison is not dated.
And who's the funniest now?
The one who makes me laugh the most is probably Joey.
Thank you.
Hear that.
He just said,
come on Joey Diaz makes me laugh harder than anybody.
He's just,
there's bursts of,
there's moments when Joey Diaz is on stage where it's funny than anything that
has ever happened in the world.
There's moments where Joey Diaz,
he hits these notes,
he says some shit sometimes they're just literally makes me fall onto the
ground.
I'll roll around in the airport,
I'll be on my back and airport,
like crying,
laughing.
He's the funniest dude ever to me.
And this is not just cause I love him and he's my brother.
But I've been around that dude for like more than a decade.
There's no one person who's made me laugh more than him.
And it's like if I had to like,
like all the laughs that I've ever achieved in my life and put it like Joey d,
the Joey [inaudible] files,
like up to the ceiling.
It's piling over like the stacks of laughs from all my friends.
But with Joey,
it's ridiculous.
I can't even really compare him to other comics.
He was like,
he's in a different categories,
different kinds of human being.
Yeah.
He's just the funniest guy of all time.
I've met a lot of fucking funny people,
man.
I've seen the greats.
I've seen Richard Pryor live a seen kicks live.
I've seen,
I've seen Chris Rock and Dave Chappelle and Louis C K I've seen them all live,
you know,
is your favorite chain.
Nobody could fuck with Joey Diaz is my,
my favorite comedian and an hour of all now.
I mean,
Richard Pryor has to be of all time.
I think he's like,
yeah,
yeah.
If you want to go with the most influential,
this is what I feel like.
I feel like it's Lenny Bruce and then slightly more.
Also,
if you look at,
if you look at Richard Prior,
the reason why I say Richard Pryor is his standup was like Red Fox on fucking
steroids.
I also love Red Fox,
but he was on like,
and you know,
grew up in a whore house.
All that shit.
Awesome.
He worked at Red Fox is club,
but then what?
I really love it shit like,
uh,
you know his,
his,
his gene wilder sort of,
you know,
movies for the masses.
You know,
I'm thinking of the one where they go to the weather,
the Rodeo and the,
they have to do the Rodeo.
Whoa.
What's that?
They go to Joe.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't remember,
but he was very fun.
Unbelievably funny.
Very funny in those movies.
Come on.
What's that movie?
I don't remember any of those movie stir crazy or something.
That's good.
God Damn Shit.
I broke your head here.
All right.
Leave it alone.
Stir crazy because I'll tell you why.
Because he was doing all the,
the,
the sort of crazy underground shit and,
and like fucked up and whores and drugs and fucking crazy mixed company here.
Right?
And then,
but also doing the movies that were just like fucking hilarious.
If I had to put like,
um,
who had the like the most impact on culture?
I would say prior.
The only reason why I say Kennison was the best for a year because I think it
was the most extraordinary example of a guy who was utterly amazing and
astonishing and impactful and then deteriorated before our eyes.
Like a,
a really almost a cartoonish version of himself,
a caricature of himself.
He just,
he fell into everything that was wrong with being famous hook,
line,
sinker.
Yes.
But he was the greatest of all time for 12 months.
Even better than prior.
I just,
the,
my feeling is that prior is the greater comedian.
He was a greater craftsmen.
He's a great,
the more honest,
the more insightful,
the more socially for a long time.
He did it for a long time and he was never bad.
He was never bad.
He was just as good the day he died.
I mean,
he had a hard time when he came back from ms and they would carry him on stage.
I don't count those sets.
I did six weeks with a dude six weeks ahead of time.
I did.
I'm at the store,
I,
I followed him for five,
it was about five and a half weeks and he would go up like two or three nights a
week and they would carry him onto the stage and he was,
but it was really hard though.
It's hard for him to communicate and you know,
but yeah,
people want him to see him before he went.
That's what it was essentially.
And it was packed.
It was packed like almost every night.
So if you had to say who's the greatest comedian of all time?
I would say it's a tie.
It's prior for the,
the length of the career and the w w w the emotional attachment,
the love that you got from his sets.
Like you got like a positivity from his sats.
You got a also,
he was just naturally fucking funny.
He was brilliant.
But Kennison was nother thing,
man for 12 months or whatever the hell it was,
1416 months.
He was another thing,
man,
he was a mother fucker.
He would cause the people who don't know what comedy was like back then.
Have a hard time understanding.
Sure.
But if you were alive,
you get into it from him from,
sure,
for sure.
It was two people.
It was prior in him,
his prior,
when I was a little kid,
my parents took me to see live that sunset strip and I was in this theater and I
remember in the middle of it dying laughing.
I remember,
I don't remember the bit,
but I was dying.
I couldn't believe how hard it was laughing.
And then I remember like holding my sides laughing Sarna and looking around at
all these people rocking back and forth in their chairs,
laughing so hard and then thinking,
this is just a guy talking.
Oh,
he's still in his talk.
And I thought about all the movies and I had seen that I really liked like
stripes,
like hilarious,
hilarious movies.
So I thought it was like the funniest thing you could ever see.
And then all the sudden I'm seeing this guy and all he's doing is talking and
it's so much funnier than that.
He didn't need a Winnebago,
he didn't need anything.
So that was the first,
that was my first inkling of standup and then Kennison was like probably the
reason why I thought maybe I could do it because I my,
my sense of humor was so much darker than like what I was seeing on like
television or what else.
There was so much more wild than when I was seeing on so much of a wild man
lives and stuff.
Wearing mood rings mysterious.
I grew up with Steve Martin,
then Joe Rogan
and Doug Stanhope pry my biggest influences and Joe Rogan made it in there.
Hell yeah.
Hello.
I've seen Joe Rogan probably more than any more than anybody in the planet for
sure.
There's more pictures of me and him together then to me with any other human
that's ever existed.
Who are the new bad boy?
He's like Jim Norton.
Norns excellent.
Yeah,
for sure.
This is a great time for stand up comedy because this is a great time for self
promotion.
But people like Thomson Cora Thompson and his wife Christina Palicki top scores
is one of the best fucking comics in the country.
But it's just letting the world know about it.
That's all it's missing.
Is it fear?
Fear.
One of the best comics in the country and people are people because of the,
the whole death squad network are sort of getting clued in to like,
who's who we're,
if we're hanging out with people,
it's because they're funny if for bringing people around cause they're funny.
And so it's spreading.
And in turn they're introducing nug.
Brian's constantly introducing new people into the mix.
He sees people at the comedy store,
he introduced him into the mix and then boom,
we know Tony Hinchcliffe now.
Hilarious Tony Hinchcliffe.
And that's,
that's like that.
This is a rare time for that.
It's a rare time where the expansion of of,
of comics has been so easy and the,
the ability to promote people's been swimming.
I wanted to ask you this question and you know,
uh,
last time we,
I was going to jail,
you know,
you've changed the world.
I love you,
but it was,
that was unimpressed.
That was me impression of me doing me drunk.
Oh God.
I was like,
I love you.
I Dunno,
I become 90 years old.
But what I wanted to say is like every time we do,
I get,
I actually,
I was in Houston coming back from Central America night.
This guy came up to me in a full on,
uh,
like,
I dunno,
Sherpa gear.
No,
like fuck it,
you know,
the bright orange,
you're going,
you know what I'm talking about?
The Bright Orange Nascar uniform things like,
he was like a air traffic controller out there,
but one of these guys,
but those guys,
what are the traffic controller right on the ground,
ground ground graph through the guy with a flashlight.
He came up,
he came up to me and he was like,
fucking Joe Rogan fucking,
you know,
you and Joe Rogan and fucking awesome.
And he was just maybe the best guy I've ever met and he was just like,
you know,
I was in the city airport and he was just so stoked and he was like death squad
desk and he showed me all this shit and then when he took a picture of me right
me and he said,
can I take a picture?
I go,
yeah,
you took a picture of me and then some other death squad dude put it up on Times
Square like in a Photoshop,
what I've seen and then everybody went and I was like,
fucking desk squad shit is crazy.
And what do you,
what?
I want to say a what the fuck is going on with that and be what?
Like how did it happen?
Like you guys have created this fucking amazing shit.
I got this too.
There's two sort of branches of it.
I'm listening,
I'm good.
I'm going to ask a question.
It's like,
and then I'm just going to leave you because I don't
give a shit about what you're saying.
What are you getting in there?
What could he possibly be getting it there?
What is he getting?
What?
I'm listening when you get in there ice,
I got something.
How dare you.
Okay.
The world,
my drink.
I'm going to ask you any questions ranking already.
I haven't even ate yet today.
No,
it was bad.
You know,
all it is is really at this point,
there's two,
two,
two branches.
One is all the stuff that Brian's doing,
Brian,
what he calls his network is the desk squad podcast network.
And it's a great connection to a lot of people that maybe you don't know or
maybe you do know and you'd never heard him talk like that.
Like Kevin Pereira or there's that.
And then there's all just sort of what we call all of us,
whether it's Ari or Dunkin or we don't really call all of us,
we don't.
But with this seal of approval of comics and friends that were all friends,
that's a good way of putting it.
But why is it and it to seal,
but it seems a little bit more than it was like more political and there,
but it's not if it chooses to be,
it's not our doing.
We're not,
all we're doing is saying all we ever say the bottom line,
don't be a con.
That's number one.
And number two,
like if I,
if I tell you the Duncan trussell's funny,
believe me,
I'm not going to bullshit.
You know?
So if we're all connected like that,
like you can guarantee you,
if I tell you Joey Diaz,
the funniest guy I've ever fucking seen in my life,
you're going to see what I'm talking about.
If you go see him live,
you know,
and so this sort of connection with each other like that,
like Brian Brian,
Brian told me about Tony Hinchcliffe.
He's like,
dude,
there's this guy,
you got to see him,
this young guy.
But seeing him at the store,
he's really fucking funny.
Like,
and he says,
I'm going to have him on one of these shows,
like the desk quad shows at the Ice House.
So he puts them on and then boom,
we know Tony Hinchcliffe is a bad motherfucker.
Rights for the burn now.
Yeah,
he's got like a real career and I brought him with me to Indianapolis,
the kids fucking hilarious.
Right?
It's like,
so what it's allowing is we can bypass all those other systems.
We don't have to,
you don't have to be on the tonight show anymore.
You don't have to wait for an HBO special.
I mean,
you can say death squad.
Love is his fucking,
it's also using subliminal messaging,
like using the planned cash till the whole thing.
This is the best part about it,
is it nobody,
nobody like is running it and nobody asked for it and nobody,
no,
no one's in charge.
No one's,
no one knows the fuck's going on.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we don't have an agenda.
There's no agenda.
We don't happen to it.
Like a little bit older and then all of a sudden you start to let a few into the
farm and if you're more than that,
it's pretty soon.
And you're like,
I've got 10,000 of these mother fuckers is no farm.
What?
Starting a civilization.
I knew you want to,
I don't want to say new civilization,
I don't want to say intellectual,
but it will be a utopian,
it's impossible.
Not In this lifetime.
Not unless a ray Kurzweil's correct.
They're going to come get you.
You download con.
If you started at court,
they would get come get my call wouldn't do shit.
No.
My call,
it would just go like fishing.
My company doesn't want to have anything to do with what you're doing.
If I,
if I had to call it,
the last thing I'd want is to dominate the financial markets like you guys can
have.
That's all you did,
right?
Have a good time.
We're going to have you want to dominate?
We're going to do Jujitsu.
We got to go fishing.
We're going to smoke weed and tell jokes.
Okay.
Is it all right?
We'll just be over here and you swear to God we're not going to do nothing.
Yeah.
You use the coupon code [inaudible] and save 10% off all home grown mangoes.
If I had a call,
two would be the easiest cult ever.
Like go stay.
I don't know what he gives a fuck.
Okay.
Nobody's trying to take over shit.
All right.
I'm going to remember that the,
I think the culture is coming.
No,
because they're spreading their own cults to like,
there's like,
like if you go to like all these,
uh,
Twitter pages now,
it's like death squad.
St Louis,
definitely.
I,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
That's why they're doing that.
No one asked him to do that.
Brian didn't know.
I didn't ask him to do that.
And by the way,
when they do it,
nobody says anything.
We don't,
I've never said any,
hey,
you can't do that,
or hey,
you shouldn't do that.
Or Hey,
we don't know you.
Or,
Hey,
what are you doing?
Why'd you choose that name?
Or no one cares,
you know,
like,
dude,
what the fuck you want to do?
Right.
That's,
that's the thing.
It's pretty awesome.
Well,
it's unexpected.
It's unexpected and unplanned and so completely uncontrolled.
And uh,
not only that,
but no one takes credit for it.
It's beautiful.
It's great.
It's just sort of like how I like how you're like,
it's unplanned on credit.
Uh,
you know that they're listening to it.
It doesn't matter.
We're not doing anything.
Go Look,
look,
if I had the society,
the perfect society wouldn't be taken over this fucking mess.
It would be like living near a lake and having a solar panel that he's my
fucking TV.
You know,
I,
I wouldn't be taking over the governor.
Love it.
Heated TV.
Yeah man.
I want to be able to,
you know,
get satellite,
whatever.
Get direct TV for in the middle of nowhere.
The last thing I would ever want to do is have any position of power over
anybody ever anywhere.
I don't even like having employees.
That's why my my loan employees,
they're both fucking crazy.
Look at him.
These two dudes are savages.
I can't have like a regular employee,
some regular dude.
It's,
I can't even communicate with people like that.
I'm worried now.
I think I'm going to go farm and there's going to be a lot of people.
There will be no count.
Me thinks like it does for cats too much.
Well,
Brian's letting out the cute,
those are on the side of the cheerios box.
Um,
so the relationship park in China,
do you know the act,
the exact address for this?
[inaudible] had a,
uh,
I think it was episode three of your show.
It was all about,
uh,
I didn't know that there's more women than men in China.
50 million,
50 million more men,
men,
the man anymore,
man.
Man,
man,
they do these things where they go to these like parks with like pretty much
like,
it's like their profile.
Like this is how much money I make.
This is my,
my house.
And it was,
and you had sent one of your reporters there to actually try it.
He didn't look like he succeeded in any of that.
It didn't work out.
Um,
uh,
it's pretty funny when Thomas goes there,
but it's actually pretty sad.
They have 50 million.
What does that,
that's a size of a fairly big country.
50 million.
50 million more men than women.
Oh God.
And so you have,
and the problem is,
is that you have,
um,
most of the women moved to the city so that,
you know,
in the cities it's okay,
it's hard,
but it's okay.
But in the countryside,
it's just dudes.
And actually one of the things that we wanted to shoot,
uh,
which we couldn't get because they,
the government fucking freaked out was they have these towns that are,
um,
just like prostitute towns and,
and,
and the only women in them are prostitutes.
All the men come in from the country and have their sex and then go back out and
now they're,
they're making these sex robots.
Did we talk about this before?
I don't think so.
No.
They're making these sort of sex robot brothels because there's literally whole
towns in the west of China that doesn't have any women.
Yeah,
I think we did.
I believe we did talk.
We might've been drunk that time.
It's insane story.
But yeah,
it's hard to wrap your head around it when you start doing genetic engineering,
you know,
Shit fucks up.
And,
and in the cities it's harder to get wives and,
but in the countries there are no women.
Oh my God.
And so when there are no women,
shit gets fucked up.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
She tossed
it.
Just terrible,
terrible idea of controlling the population in that way.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
the amount of people that someone can have,
it's interesting because you say,
you say,
okay,
well we're just too many people so we have to have one kid,
but you figure,
well it'd be 50 50 but then if you put societal sort of constraints or cultural
constraints and say,
well,
we want the lineage to go on so we want a boy.
So actually they started a boarding girls were getting rid of the girl and then
all of a sudden you have 50 million,
which in China,
you know it's,
it's more than a billion people.
So 50 million doesn't seem like a lot,
but 50 million fucking people.
That's the size of Germany and it's more men than women.
They're like,
that must be just a social chaos.
Like doing must be so much depression and the relationships you want to eat
pussy whipped dude.
But did you see the guy?
They just,
the most interesting thing I think about that piece is the rich guys actually
take out billboards for themselves and take to advertise.
It's pretty awesome.
But the schlubs like the regular guys,
the guys who are like,
you know,
just a regular dude with a regular job,
they're like,
we cannot get a girl.
Like we're just,
we just can't compete to get their regular good guys like doing a good job doing
whatever.
But they can't compete against the guy buying a fucking billboard like
crazy.
Go Gay.
Is there a big gay population there or is it,
you know,
a lot of it in,
in,
in China is,
is mostly cultural too because it's also like we have to take care of our
parents and it's a,
it's a sort of economic relationships and all this stuff.
Wow.
So actually the,
you know,
there are places like,
let's say Thailand where like,
you know,
the sort of gay population,
sorry.
But I think in China they're actually coming up with like robotic.
Wow.
Well the only good thing about that is it no one,
you know,
maybe within a generation they'll have their population and the control of the
point where they're going to allow people to have as many kids as they want.
Is that possible?
That's actually declining now.
Whereas India,
India is now,
I believe,
bigger than China and it,
it,
it did that in the last five or 10 years.
Oh,
quicker.
It has the youngest population in the world and because they didn't have any
sort of curtailing and now China has sort of leveled off or declining and India
just went through the roof.
Wow.
Yeah.
India seems like a really insane place.
I've had friends that told me they went to India and like as soon as they got
over there that felt like they made a mistake.
Like this is like,
this is too much.
It's too crazy.
Too many,
too many bags.
Definitely gives you an insight into what cities used to be like because they
already have and have not there as well.
That's like stag road.
We did a piece on that.
The,
the most expensive and largest house on the planet is in Mumbai,
which is a 28 story mansion for one dude.
Right.
Uh,
cost,
uh,
it has a staff of 380.
It costs like 400 grand a month just to fucking keep going.
It's like this crazy skyscraper for one guy.
Wow.
Cut.
But the craziest thing,
but the thing is,
it comes out of,
it comes out of uh,
a fucking slum and the slum isn't just like,
like what we think of as a slum.
Like whenever I come to California,
I'm like,
hold on,
this is a bad neighborhood.
Everyone's got to fucking house.
Like it's like,
you know,
but,
but when you're talking about a slum there,
it's like,
like they have one toilet for every 1700 inhabitants of slow.
So everything reeks of Shit.
Everything weeks they make all their money off,
just the garbage of the regular economy.
So like half the economy of Mumbai is,
we take the garbage,
whatever that was thrown out,
food,
plastic,
whatever.
And we recycler,
we redo it and we fucking,
that's it.
And so the thing is,
is you're sitting there and where people are like sleeping under their sewing
machines where they make a bucket and stuff,
and then you walked down the street and then it's like boom,
straight out of the same thing.
A billion or I think it's 1.8 billion.
Multi billion over a billion dollar house.
38 stories.
Two Olympic size swimming pools,
like observation decks,
400,000 square feet.
And you're like,
you just take the elevator down,
walk two blocks and you're in like 50 people sleeping in a room this big.
Yeah,
it's fucked up.
That is so gangster live like that.
Like that's like so old school gangster.
Well it's a,
yeah,
it's how the kings used to live.
Everyone was born,
the king was rich.
It's insane.
What must that guy's reality be like?
Like the beads that far in the opposite.
You know what's interesting about India is,
I don't know if it's,
if it's,
you know,
Hinduism or whatever,
but it's like,
they're like,
yeah,
we're super poor.
We can't eat.
He's got a billion dollar house.
Well,
really it's not great.
But whereas in Europe they're like,
I'm not going to burn that shit down.
I'm going to fucking some brave fucking take your shit and I'm going to eat it.
Yeah.
That would not fly.
Oh,
same thing in Arab spring right now.
I mean young people are saying,
fuck it,
I don't give a fuck.
Well,
isn't that weird about the world?
Like what we're talking about?
Like the,
the variations of these different countries and what flies in one place.
We hear about in some places and you go like,
okay,
how about New Guinea?
Do you know about those people that live and they,
the semen warriors of New Guinea.
It is the most
Ernie,
but new Guinea is got every good story in the world.
We're doing it.
You got it right there.
And I'm sure they got a lot of them,
like all the crazy like,
you know,
cargo cults,
cargo cults.
What's the cargo cult?
Come on.
I don't know.
My favorite time cargo.
Yeah.
Cargo look up cargo cult as I explained what it is.
Okay.
So Papua New Guinea was a staging point for the American army during World War
II and they cut these impossible,
uh,
runways into the jungle.
Right?
And,
but the people who were living there were like Bronze Age people.
And so they saw these planes come out and then,
and then you know,
they would give them like spam and whatever,
like stuff,
you know,
parachutes.
And so then the left at the end of the war and the started a whole religion on
the plane.
So they built these planes and they come in and they mimic the landing and they
mimic the people coming out and they still have the American uniforms and the,
the,
the tribesmen would like a bone through his nose and you like one dread we'll
come out with like,
you know,
captain fucking Joe Adams,
and then they'll,
they'll bring like the lat,
the empty cam of cans of spam and shit.
And they have these like planes made out of flowers that they pretend to launch
and stuff.
And you're like,
this is the craziest fucking really watching religion they made.
They made the religion because of the planes,
you know the beef 52 is coming with supplies and the whole religion is like the
plane is the vessel of God and the Captain Joe Abrams who comes out is the
[inaudible] God and the next ring you the spam.
Giorgio sucralose would spike his hair up and come in here and say,
is it possible that the reason why these things exist that we learned them from
aliens?
Yeah,
I mean it makes sense if if you lived to stone age life and a plane landed and
gave you some spam,
100% it would become folklore and it's gotta be so strange if they are,
they are.
They are.
They are literate culture.
So no,
I mean hold on.
They just tell stories.
Yeah.
The cargo called,
they do,
they do the whole religious thing through the reenacting that when the planes
first landed,
but actually there's a thing now,
they are kind of littered now because these,
these people in New Guinea who are fighting Exxon,
there's a lot of oil there.
And excellence,
trying to turn to,
um,
exploit the oil and these,
uh,
hair.
They,
well,
whatever,
everyone's going to get oil.
Cause if there's fucking oils and one's going to get it,
but they,
they have this trial but they have this tribe now that's dressing as um,
you know,
the gods,
the car,
the cargo,
and they're attacking Exxon dressed as American servicemen from 1942.
I think the whole theme of this is from American 1942 today.
But like it's,
it's cause they make big,
huge white helmets.
And then,
uh,
if you Google God,
that's Google,
uh,
Papa New Guinea versus Exxon.
And you'll see the crazy outfits they have John's,
he doesn't know it as bell pass out or New Guinea.
He barely knows how spells,
it's pretty fucking interesting that there's a whole,
it's a huge country popping is massive.
And there's a whole like how big Texas sized,
much bigger than Texas.
And you have a big,
big country where like,
uh,
like huge pockets of it worship cargo from 1944.
God,
I changed up 42 to 40.
Is there,
is there a big city like we can go and get Wifi and the Starbucks,
um,
does that too.
There's that too.
It's just like a cheesecake factory there.
There might be like,
can you go get a Starbucks?
Can I get a Starbucks?
If I went to New Guinea,
you can probably get some sort of pizza hut product.
Wow.
I don't know about Starbuck.
I saw a giant coca cola billboard in the Yucatan.
I was like,
this is the nuttier Shit I've seen in my life driving into the jungle and the
weight of the Mayan Ruins and is a giant ad for sugar.
Water.
Oak is everywhere.
It's everywhere.
Everywhere you go,
it's actually everywhere you go.
Except for a lot of the Muslim world because they only drink Pepsi because
somebody spread a rumor that Coca Cola had sort of funded design as a movement.
Whoever did that as a marketing tool was fucking smart.
Just Pepsi.
What does that mean?
Hey,
easy,
easy.
What does that mean?
Design,
ISM,
Zionism,
Zionism and sow and sow and sow.
Peptide.
Pepsin is designed ism.
And so Pepsi's now bigger in all these countries.
You're like,
cause I'm a coke fan.
I don't like Pepsi.
I bet you are.
Where's the ice son?
Alright.
Um,
yeah,
take both soc.
Let's be honest.
I've been trying to drink water.
Larry bad.
You're,
you're a healthy guy.
I've been more healthy lately or helped the guy.
I'm gluten free for one week.
I'll beautiful try.
I eat,
I eat everything.
I'm a fucking,
I do too.
But
I've been a the garbage I do too.
I don't know.
I'm,
when I say garbage,
I mean I like street.
Meet me to,
you know,
any,
any place I can get a Kebab.
That's what I'm talking about,
dog.
I'll give it up.
I'll,
I'll fold like a house of cards.
He burnt charred meat.
I'll eat it.
Yeah,
no,
I agree in that
strong.
I'm a fat.
I'll stop this.
I'm gray inside.
A great ashes.
Ashes,
wink,
wink.
She ashy gray,
horrible gray and fluid and pink and strong and bureau.
The guys get him.
Yeah,
this is getting gross.
Are Ready.
Um,
I wanted to talk to you about,
there was some,
some article that who,
who got nasty with you lately.
It was a lot of people getting nasty.
There was someone that said something about a,
you lying about your past.
Sure.
Yeah.
What was that all know all
about?
You know,
it's interesting because when I was studying in,
uh,
I studying political science about Paul and the first I was in first year
probably sign a guy goes to me,
he goes,
I was,
he was a southern guy even though he was in Canada.
And he goes,
I was running a race and we were losing the race and we were fighting the
incumbent,
the governor.
And uh,
I said to my client,
uh,
we have to tell the people that he's having,
you know,
Congo relations with farm animals and the,
the income is my vote.
Yeah.
Roger,
I let the guy goes,
you know,
the,
the young sort of idealists guy goes like,
I will not say that the governor of whatever it is,
Alabama is a,
has carnal knowledge.
It's fucking pigs.
You know,
I'm not going to do that.
I know him.
He's a good man.
Whenever he goes,
you know,
and by the way,
he doesn't do it.
Like we can't,
you know,
to impinge his character.
And,
and,
and the,
the guy who was teaching me this political class goes,
you know,
all you've got to do is say he's a pig fucker.
Because then the minute he says,
I am not a pig fucker,
everyone will know that he is a pig fucker.
So the,
the interesting thing for me is that I'm just this dude like doing vice,
do my things,
do my documentaries.
And when we did the HBO show and it got bigger and bigger,
and then all of a sudden,
it's not just the far right,
it's the far left.
Everyone starts taking potshots cause like,
oh,
here's these guys and we're trying to make,
uh,
you know,
impartial fucking documentaries and try and do news and Shit.
And they start taking these potshots and it's a great question because my
initial reaction is like,
you're going to talk to my ex girlfriends off the record.
You know,
you're going to fucking go.
There was nobody speaking on the record.
You're going to fucking go,
whatever.
And then I realized I'm defending myself against Shit that's just total horse
shit.
So it was just a piece.
It's a total head piece and then I'm sitting there going,
okay,
that's how it starts.
Like,
cause we've had this discussion where you sit there and the the left sits there
and makes their comedy jokes about,
no,
you did this and you said this.
I'll Rodney in a rottie just as a fucking school yard bully and everybody's just
attacking,
attacking everybody else's character and all this shit.
When I said either I'm going to fucking go down there in the trenches and start
spewing shit and say,
no,
I didn't do this.
No,
I did not fuck pigs or I'm just going to keep on fucking making the shit that
I'm making and I'm not going to fucking enter into the shit.
Is it true?
No.
Is it fucking a hit pcs from the fucking,
you know,
whatever.
But hold on.
I've had them from the right,
from the left,
from anybody.
Okay.
Little this,
let's just be specific.
What are the accusations?
Well,
I've had a lot this,
there's several specific ones lately about your past,
about your journalist history.
Sure.
Well,
what did their shifts,
there's,
there's shit from like,
you know,
25 years ago.
And by the way,
I can't talk a lot about this because you know,
with these things,
it gets a bit legal.
Right?
I see what you're saying.
Um,
because a lot of it's just horse shit and you're like,
okay,
so we'll,
we'll look at that.
Um,
and I'm not actually going to get into know,
like the slinging of the shit and defending myself because that's what I said.
I'm just going to make my shit and do what I don't want you to express yourself
in any way that you're not comfortable with.
And the whole thing about,
you know,
whenever people discuss their past,
the idea that anybody has right to talk to you about your past at all to me is I
feel like if someone wants to talk to me about their past,
then they choose to do so.
But if they don't,
the idea you can pry into someone's past is completely ridiculous.
I can or I cannot th th th the thing about it is,
uh,
when somebody does something that's wrong,
then you can rectify that in a,
in an adult manner,
which is what we're doing.
Um,
what did we rectifying?
Yeah,
look,
you know,
again,
we're going to get into sort of legal shit,
right?
Okay.
But the reality of it is,
is that,
you know,
look,
am I perfect?
No,
you're beautiful.
Thank you.
So like a Whitney Houston Song?
No,
it's not when he used to be,
by the way,
but by the way,
I don't want it matter what they say and do.
I do.
I drank too much to anyone.
No,
no,
no.
He drank the exact amount.
You,
but,
but it's perfect.
But if I made a conscious decision about this,
if somebody's talking shit,
I'll let fucking lawyers and other people deal with that and I'm going to
fucking make my shit because what I'm not going to do is get into this laugh he
site,
she said,
political,
I fucking attack you.
You attack me.
Then we attack each other and no one's making the fucking news.
And I'm going to do is I'm going to make the fucking news and do the stories
that I want to do.
If people want to fucking attack me,
they can fucking attack me.
And by the way,
if they want to about my girlfriend's off the fucking record,
if they want to talk about shit from fucking whatever,
right?
If they want to get like x employees that fucking never speak on the record,
it's a whole fun.
So if I could encapsulate it,
what will you basically saying is it's all bullshit and to talk about it sort of
like it's what they're trying to do is they see that there's a lot of energy and
a lot of a lot of attention eyes on this whole vice thing.
Whether it's your HBO show,
whether it's the web,
the web,
there's a lot of energy going on and for anybody not to be,
this is my personal opinion of course,
but not to be appreciative of all the content that you guys put out.
There's so much interesting shit from Hamilton Morris stuff.
Hamilton Mars stuff is brilliant.
I love that guy.
He's a weird guy.
On the podcast because vice vice does a lot of stuff.
The one thing is is I'm the face,
I'm the face of vice a.
So people on both sides are going to come after me.
Fine.
And I'm,
by the way,
like I said,
if you want to avoid criticism,
don't go anywhere.
Don't meet anyone.
Don't say anything.
Okay?
So my whole thing is we're going to go out there and make our shit.
Are people going to have goes at us on both sides of the fucking spectrum?
Yes.
Am I going to fucking get down there?
And every time someone says your girlfriend said you didn't fucking whack off,
right?
No,
I don't give a fuck.
So they can fuck off.
Yeah.
Girls are wanting to talk about the way you whack off ex-girlfriend.
Dare you ladies.
By the way,
by the way,
you have to look at the source and if you're going to sit there and say,
okay,
I'm going to go to some dude's ex girlfriends from 20 fucking years ago,
friends,
you know,
if you're a girl and you got to deal with some Douche bag dude from your past,
it makes up shit about you.
That's gotta suck too.
Cause it's like human beings.
It's like when,
when he had,
we had baron on yesterday,
he was talking about his divorce and the insanity of a person that used to love
try and take everything you have is your house.
And it was fascinating.
Absolutely fucking fascinating.
But that's humans,
man.
That's what I,
what I find interesting about America right now is anyone that comes up trying
to say,
look,
you know what?
We're going to try to do something.
We're going to try to do something different.
We're going to stay away from the fucking regular way to most fucking people are
doing this shit because it hasn't worked.
They just have a go at you and you're like,
I'm just trying to fucking do my shit,
dude.
Like you're having a go at me like,
well,
and by the way,
I've got to say,
if that's your best,
go at me then.
So there's nothing,
no merit to it.
We were saying it's just no merit.
Okay.
So all the things they're saying you did or didn't do,
you actually did do.
And all the things they're saying,
look,
again,
it's going to get into legal.
I understand what you're saying,
but,
but the,
uh,
so it's a hit job.
Exactly.
So they're trying to find some flaw in your character and they're going to the
for what,
what do you do when they don't want,
they don't want you to say shit and they say,
okay,
whatever,
you know,
well,
you have to be like me and have zero credibility is the best.
The other thing that's interesting is I've always said,
look,
if you're looking at advice for everything,
then we're at to begin with,
because,
you know,
we used to,
as you pointed out,
we used to be this and that.
However,
look,
have we evolved?
Have we done shit?
Have we gone from talking about sneakers to news?
Yeah.
And by the way,
if you go back in my life,
have I done drugs have been a bad boy.
Right?
What the fuck?
What are you doing promoting drug use?
Not On my show.
Not,
I'm not sure if this is America as my America.
You're Canadian.
You don't even American.
Goddammit.
We're all competent together.
We're all congress in a certain way.
Right.
In a certain way.
I mean socialists not really little medicine wise.
They're just a rich country so they can spread some money around.
I was just going to ask you,
why are they so rich and is it like a fake false of like are they going to have
a boom with her like finance or real estate?
This is what it is is because they're not cunts and they didn't get robbed.
Okay.
They had a totally different country.
It's a big country with not that many people.
Harder to fuck everybody over and they didn't have the home mortgage crisis that
we had.
Yeah.
And also,
I mean it's,
you know,
there's so much resource welt up there as well as banking,
as well as tech as well as everything else.
But they have just a lot of resources and not a lot of people.
Yeah.
And they're friendlier.
That helps too.
That helps people are the same,
pretty much the most.
You're out of your mind.
You can feel it.
I don't agree with that.
I think there's a lot of friendly people in this country is Canadians can be
pretty hypocritical
backwards.
No.
Well,
what I will say is there a little bit hypocritical because they'll say we're not
American.
You know,
we give out foreign aid.
We're nicer,
we're better.
We're kinder,
but an actual fact,
it's a bunch of Hokum.
And,
and how do you disrespect?
Like what,
what,
what is,
uh,
what's come about it?
Well,
like we give out four and eight for sure,
but we,
a lot of the times we were giving it to the bad guys.
You know,
who,
who were running these different countries.
We gave out,
for example,
candy reactors.
And we said,
hey,
by the way,
nobody used this,
a radioactive plutonium that comes out of here for any other things,
you know,
and,
and also when,
so they gave it away.
They gave,
they gave,
they gave candy rack,
reactor technology away to why I believe Pakistan and India right now,
which is John.
So Kathy,
I think Pakistan and India,
their nukes,
I believe Pakistan through uh,
a que con and France and some of North Korea a weaponized it.
But I believe that the initial,
um,
reactors both from India,
I'm for sure India,
but I'm pretty sure it,
Pakistan came from Canada.
She's Christ.
But in any case,
the reason why I say that,
it's just because we're like,
we're like holding a little bit holier than that.
We're like,
well,
you know,
we're nicer.
We're richer.
We have universal healthcare.
We have,
let's look at that.
Because look at that decision.
That decision was only made by,
I mean how many people,
how many people were involved in the decision to sell arms to other countries.
It's probably a very small cell.
Give.
Okay.
Give even getting w w there was some influence.
There's something,
something in exchange.
I think Canada is the largest donator of foreign aid per capita in the world.
That's our,
that's our big thing.
Just giving people money,
owing people money,
whatever you do with it,
fine,
but do it.
No,
but there's a lot of sanctimonious sort of like,
we're great,
we're nice,
we're cool.
You know,
we don't fuck with anybody where everybody likes us.
Some of my favorite people that ever met a Canadian,
but you know,
at the same time,
you know,
it's,
we say,
okay,
you know,
we have this great education system,
we have this great healthcare system,
but it's a two tiered system.
Nobody admits it,
but it is,
you know,
it cuts off the tall trees.
It May,
it may be a two tiered system,
but it's so much better for the lower tier.
Correct.
Then the system that it's in America.
Yeah.
I think you're going to hear it.
But America system is fun.
Sane.
It's,
you know,
it's just fun.
It's fun.
It's chaos.
You should do a special about if the hundred dollar bill in Canada actually
really is purposely smells like maple syrup or if it's just box.
I never did.
You know that I knew,
I knew one of the bills melted the new,
the new,
the new currency is made out of plastic and it melts or in the dryer but it's
really hot.
But the hundred dollar bill smells like maple syrup like,
and it really,
why would she have money that melts in the dryer?
That's fucking stupid.
You can't rip it though.
You tried to rip it and can't rip it.
But if it melts that dryer,
who,
what's more likely that you're gonna Rip Your Shit?
Are you going to leave it in your pocket?
I don't know.
I will say one thing,
a lot of times I'd take out a bills and I give them to people in foreign
countries and America money looks counterfeit cause like the faces will be all
blurred and shit so shitty to,
and it'll be all like,
you know,
you hand over like a hundred analogue and in Thailand or China and they're like
that's not real.
Yeah.
Cause like the whole thing is like wiped out and faded shitty.
And you're like,
that can't be real honey.
She's had like their money,
like I was at pink diet and they have this wall of like every single like
currency they've ever got from every single country.
And there's some like currency that's like really baby looks like a little
monopoly money.
Cute.
I don't know.
It's,
there's a lot of countries that have that.
Canada has dope money.
They have like little windows clear windows.
You fuckers shit.
No I don't.
Oh I do.
This is my favorite.
Somebody gave this to me recently and they're like,
here,
this is when shit gets out of hand.
Uh Oh yeah,
there you go.
That's real.
That's real money.
What is this for?
What countries?
Zimbabwe.
$50 billion.
Oh yeah,
that's real.
It's a,
it's like a dog.
It's like 17 cents or something like that.
50 billion.
$50 billion.
This is $50 billion.
That's 50 billion.
Turn the camera on.
That is it.
There you go.
That's $50 billion inc.
That's real though.
This is what's weird.
She just told about that same exact bill last night.
She's like,
check this out.
And she showed you now have a 1 trillion.
I'm 50 billion now.
It's like one trip.
So what's the exchange rate?
Wayne have that,
what's the exchange rate?
What's that worth?
17 cents or something like that.
She said you're look it up.
No Way.
Louis Billion Zimbabwe in dollars versus an American dollar.
What's the exchange rate for
dollars in Zimbabwe?
[inaudible] Zimbabwe dollars versus the United States.
That's
pretty good.
And also I'd like to graphic,
I'd like to,
I'd like to graphic to be a little bit better than a rock.
It looks like poop.
It's just,
you know,
it looks like a dog just took a Doodoo of dollars.
33 cents.
No,
well no,
no.
$50 billion.
It's 33 cents.
Yep.
Well,
I guess there's been a little declining economy.
Don't worry about it folks.
I could never happen in the air.
It's not like we're all just human.
Wow.
John,
worry about it.
Could you imagine a $50 billion for 33 cents then my whole farming fishing idea,
making a lot of sense.
What's your from Matthew?
How much does that money cost though to make it has to be more,
it's gotta be cost more than 13 cents.
No,
no,
no.
When no one gets paid and everyone eats rice,
she can get people to pinch it up pretty cheap.
Yeah,
trust me.
All right,
well that the 13th census,
it's insane.
I mean,
what we just,
it's like,
it's a Coen brothers movie.
It's,
it's a Cohen brothers movie about a country somewhere in the world where
everything's collapsing and these are human beings and they coexist with people
that have a Samsung Galaxy s four that can survive 10 feet underwater for like
an hour.
Everyone's living in the same time.
It's crazy.
It's true.
But how do you also,
how do you,
like,
you have to go with a,
like a wheelbarrow full of cash to buy like Brighton
can of corn.
Well,
that's what we always heard about the downfall,
the Soviet Union.
Do you remember that they would talk about lines for potatoes and stuff,
whether or not,
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I'm not,
you know,
obviously I really don't know what happened.
I wasn't there,
I didn't see it,
but I can't assume that those stories were bullshit.
I bet people really food for us.
It's really hard for us to wrap our head around the idea that society can fall
apart like that because we,
we haven't seen in her lifetime go to a supermarket.
You go to the supermarket here,
he's like,
fuck,
we got everything.
It's the history of the world though.
His shit falling apart.
Yes.
They hit the history of the world and shit falling apart and people figuring out
new and innovative ways to stop it from happening again.
And then that works for a little while and then their grandchildren getting
charged and then it all falls apart again.
And then it keeps going on with a cry for revolution can be just switched up
with the cry for bread.
Yes,
we're fucking hungry.
That's fucking fight.
Or for books.
I mean,
you know,
they were trying to stop people from having you know that.
Well,
I wouldn't reading this thing about Martin Luther and the idea of,
I'm a huge fan of a Dan Carlin's podcast.
Hardcore history,
right.
I talk about on the show all the time.
And one of the things I talked about is,
uh,
that I,
listened to recently rather cause he's got this whole thing about Lutherism and
about Martin Luther being the first guy to translate the Bible phonetically in a
way that people can understand.
And that before that the Bible was only in Latin and most poor people had no
idea what it said.
They didn't understand the words of the Bible.
And this became like this crazy heresy that this guy had done this given the
Bible is all these people.
And it's when you,
when you hear about shit like that and you realize that this is just sort of
always been going on,
is this control and this,
this,
this thing that we see today with the NSA and with the idea of drones.
And the idea is that,
you know,
that we look,
we got to check your everybody's email because one of you might be a terrorist.
You almost want to stop and put your hand over your heart and go,
oh my God,
dude.
You hear what you're saying?
Like you're a movie.
You're a character in a Coen brothers movie,
you're the most evil and ridiculous of dictators ever in the most prosperous of
time.
But that's where the vanity is.
There is like,
do people have moments of sanity and realize what they're doing?
Yeah,
because like if you ever like,
you know,
for example,
Libya,
you know,
you're like Gaddafi started as a man of the people.
He started a revolution and then all of a sudden you've got these mercenaries
killing your own people and Shit and you're like,
do you ever wake up?
You're sitting on the can and do you ever say,
Hey,
I'm killing my own people.
Same thing now in,
in,
in um,
in Syria,
like usually shooting there,
you're trying to hold on to power and you're like,
okay,
we fucked shit up.
Hundreds of thousands of people are getting fucked up.
You know,
tens of thousands of people is getting killed.
Like,
these are my people.
I'm supposed to be like a progressive.
He was educated at Oxford.
He must at some point know what the fuck he's would imagine.
You would imagine.
I have to call bullshit on my own self because me saying that like that anyone
at any point in time is like the,
the,
like you'll go back to Hitler.
Hitler at one time it was like the most evil controlling,
dominant dictator in history.
But that's just because that's where he lived.
Like he was in.
He was in that time.
He was dealing with the past.
But if you stop and look at numbers,
look at the overall numbers of humans killed.
It's like there's always some new thing.
There's always some new focus,
point of energy and destruction.
Whether you go back to the Mongols,
you go to Hitler,
you go to,
what you're dealing with is a human characteristic that embodies itself in a
charismatic and enigmatic figure.
Yeah.
But it's a human characteristic.
This,
this,
this want and need for destruction is doing things that you're terrified of
having done,
done to you.
It's almost,
it's,
it's a,
it's almost an unavoidable human characteristics and it's,
it's incredibly fascinating to me.
It's incredibly fascinating to me.
Just if was,
uh,
it was,
an alien watching us from another planet trying to figure out what's going on
with people,
that would be an incredibly fascinating aspect of it.
Well,
what I,
what I find interesting,
two things.
One is,
uh,
you look at that time,
let's say the 30s,
forties,
50s,
and you say,
okay,
Hitler killed all these people,
very bad guy.
Stalin killed twice as many as Hitler,
very,
very bad guy and Mao killed three times as many in his own country.
And then at that point you're like,
what the fuck was going on back then?
A B.
My second point is when you look at,
uh,
like shit,
like what's happening now?
And you say,
okay,
how does that actually happen?
You know,
like how do we get to that point?
And what happens is,
you know,
you sit there and you say,
okay,
you know,
I went to school and I learned this,
I learned this,
but you get cavalier and this is all these guys and the NSA or CIA or whatever.
Like,
you know what is like doctors,
you know,
doctors are sort of like,
oh well I deal with livers everyday.
So I lik lift up the liver,
I take out the fucking thing,
it put it down and they're kind of cavalier about the livers cops or cavalier
about the mafia.
Everyone's cavalier about the shit.
What happens in the NSA is like,
yeah,
we're listening to the guys of course were listening to the guys because fucking
we're listening to the guys and you're like,
yeah,
but you're fucking up everything.
Democracy,
freedom,
fucking private fucking shit life everything.
Yeah,
yeah.
But fucking,
you know,
we got,
we got to listen to these guys to get our shit done.
And once you just become cavalier about shit and to go back to it,
it's like,
okay,
these people aren't,
you know,
part of the revolution or they're not part of the thing they've got to be done
away with.
That's the problem is when you take the humanity out of Shit and when you take
and it's just like your day in day out job,
it's like,
oh I got to make the donuts or fry the eggs or whatever.
That's the problem with running a corporation.
When you're dealing with the bottom line all the time.
That's the number one complaint that people have bought corporations is that
they remove humanity there.
Remove the repercussions for doing things.
The environment there removed the repercussions for influencing politicians are
the restrictions for influencing politicians
and if a government is,
what is it,
you know,
one fifth of the,
of the population,
then it becomes standard operating procedure.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I believe it's not only do I think it's not healthy,
it doesn't have to happen that way.
Like I don't,
I don't think that there's something wrong with capitalism and competition
because I think that that fuels people and I think everybody looks at it in
terms of like competition is bad and those are your enemies.
No,
I think it fuels you to do better for,
I think there's nothing wrong with being in competition with other companies,
but we try communism glacier,
we try communism.
It didn't work well with this.
Capitalism works or even if it doesn't work,
it's it.
It's a system.
It can be,
I think there could be,
it is,
there can be a moral capitalism and a,
a moral,
ethical,
honorable capitalism.
But I'm just saying capitalism one.
Yeah.
Between,
you know,
gold war between communism and not perfect,
but
it makes the most sense.
And it's just one is,
it is.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the dominance.
You can't just expect people to work.
If you force them into a job,
you can't,
you're stifling creativity or you're stunting progression,
you're fucking up the whole cycle of humanity.
You can't do it if you take out incentive.
Yes.
It's not going to,
well that's a huge problem.
Like there's,
I am,
I'm not a,
I'm not really a right wing guy and I'm not a left wing guy,
but there's a lot of like really insensitive shit that gets said about people
that go on welfare,
you know?
And like the idea is that you,
oh,
they become lazy and they don't do shit and they just want to fucking lay around
and get their check.
Like maybe,
but that's not the way to handle it.
For humans like you,
you can't help people that went to Prague can't just give them money like that.
The problem is is if you look at history,
there's always pretty much around 10% of the population that just doesn't fit
in.
Like it just,
there's a different system.
It could be communism,
could be capitalism,
it could be whatever,
but they just can't get the shit together to work within that system and wash
his heart.
Yeah.
She didn't charted and washes 10% of the fucking people that just aren't going
to get there.
It could be agrarian,
could be industrial,
it could be political,
could be anything.
It was just going to be 10% that just can't get there.
They just don't get it.
They can't fill out the forms that can't fucking whatever the fuck.
So when they have to do they have to find a better gig?
Well,
I'm,
I think it's part of the human equation.
Just need people there for some reason.
I don't know why,
but part of the human equation is there's just always going to be 10% of the
people you got to go.
I give to the fucking,
I dunno,
church as a soup kitchen or whatever.
They're like,
just,
they're not going to get there.
They're just not going to get there.
And is that just the broad spectrum of biology in of itself?
I think Trey by the waterhole.
Thanks.
So I think it's literally just like,
there's always 10% of the people for better,
for worse.
I don't know why.
I don't,
I don't like,
but it's fucked up.
It's a self fulfilling prophecy to fuck that.
Once you get locked into a,
a system of poverty to get out,
it's very difficult.
It's hard to see the way out target,
you know?
Even though you see prosperity in front of you,
it's hard to see like our logical way to achieve that for yourself.
I came up,
you know,
in Montreal,
which is the most sort of anticapitalist city in the world.
And Really?
Yeah.
Anticapitalist and we'll wear,
I don't know much.
Look,
all I know about Montreal is,
it's beautiful and it's awesome.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
It's awesome being there.
It's literally one of the best cities in the fucking shout out to Joe beef.
Uh,
but they like,
they,
it's just,
it's a weird,
you know,
artistic community where community,
they want to separate from Canada or they did,
um,
it just,
it,
it was like they didn't give a fuck about just success like Toronto so much or I
was richer and bigger and more powerful than Toronto.
And then at some point Toronto said,
yeah,
we're going to be like New York.
And Montreal said,
we're just going to fucking do our own thing so much.
You're all became like its own weird,
you know,
beautiful,
crazy place in Toronto became a wanting to be in New York.
So,
you know,
it's,
when I say anticapitalist it's like for example,
bands like
Godspeed you black emperor or a arcade fire,
they're like,
we're not going to go on major labels.
Like you know,
all kinds of people are like,
we don't care about money.
Well that's a good question.
I mean,
arcade fire,
RK fires,
one of the biggest bands as well.
[inaudible] camper is like more uh,
you know,
uh,
or,
or Kestrel cool orchestral shit.
I'll try some of that business.
So who's one of the biggest bands in the world?
I never even heard of them.
They're fucking off.
What kind of music is it are awesome.
Polka fucking jazz.
Poca Rock,
rock,
rock and roll.
Rock and roll music.
Yeah.
Like if you had to compare him to someone,
that's the goal.
That's why they're so good is because it can't anybody else yet
a teeny bit.
I don't think we can,
unfortunately.
I'll listen to it off the air.
How do you say their name though?
And how do you spell arcade?
Fire.
Like,
like arcade game fire.
Anyway,
arcade fire.
Okay.
Listen to him on the way home.
What's draws a great town,
but no one cares about money.
And by the way,
that's what makes it great.
It's fantastic.
Well,
I really enjoyed it there.
I love a lot of very smart people that came out of their vice,
came out of there a place.
It's a fantastic fucking,
uh,
an excellent community of human beings.
It's fantastic.
Does that place,
the comedy works?
You know,
that place it's been around since,
but they used it.
The,
yeah.
Yeah,
Just for laughs in English.
They have a,
I was on there in 93.
Yeah.
Old schools.
I want to be a Canadian.
I don't want him,
I want to get out of here really.
Well you can,
if you want to go to the Philippines,
you can be an ask pat.
Did I ever tell you that?
Don't want an 80 in the Canadian journalists Philippines story.
No one ever told you that.
I don't think so.
I want to make that fucker a movie.
Okay.
I'll do it quick.
But it's a,
it's a true story.
There was a,
uh,
once upon a Time magazine called Saturday night in Canada,
which was the only time Canadian magazines were any good at one magazine.
That one magazine called Saturday night and they had this one writer and he was
like d rider.
He was like the Joe Rogan podcast,
but a variety of magazines.
Oh,
you're too kind.
And so he,
he was like this really respected,
like,
like he was like our young,
I don't know,
like a young hunter s Thompson like coming up like changing shit.
Anyway,
he kind of disappears,
like goes off.
And he had this young protege,
right?
Who,
who started writing going like,
what the fuck happened to my guy?
And they had the,
they were like having this real like what the fuck's going on?
But in the magazine it turns out that this guy,
this writer,
like real smart and credible writer,
whatever,
went over to the Philippines to write a story and disappeared,
right?
And then,
uh,
his protege goes,
I'm going to go find him,
right?
I'm going to go get this guy.
Oh,
and then what happens is that it's this,
now this is,
you got to imagine this is like politically correct Canada,
like really super liberal,
like right.
Politically correct.
Anyway,
okay.
So he goes over there and it turns out that this super,
like the most respected writer in the best magazine ended up living in a
whorehouse with like a young Filipino girl and he's,
he,
he went like Kurt's into the jungle and he was like,
I'm not coming back.
So the,
so then actually I remember I got the story because he came back and he was like
in a,
in a Canadian supermarket and like he was letting the girl back,
no,
he had just come back for like Christmas or something,
supplies.
And he wrote this completely,
he wrote this completely scathing thing about the supermarket saying all this
food is shit.
It's fucking an edible.
The person at the fucking thing is like w pimply face.
They don't treat you nice.
But literally he just like basically had a scathing thing on Canada.
Now you have to imagine what happened to all the people cause they went
attacking Canada,
fuck you and fuck you know,
you're fucking in.
So there was this huge,
huge outpouring of like animosity towards this dude.
So then he has his protege goes,
you know,
and he's like,
fuck this guy.
And what happened to him?
And we've got to figure out what happened that you got him at Canadian fucking
apocalypse now.
Most of it.
So exactly.
So he goes over to Philippines to get him,
he's doing a horse stance and his underwear never asked,
never forget the first uh,
line of like,
cause it's,
it's really sanctimonious and against the sky and against his,
you know,
his mentor and all this stuff.
And he goes over and the first line of his dispatch from the Philippines is,
I shouldn't have put my tongue into her pussy because now it's covered with,
I mean film.
So he's gone there and he's gone,
he's gone.
He's gone into the heart of darkness.
And it is the hard anyways,
and this is all by the way,
and sort of my rose tinted retrospect,
but I was like,
what a great buddy film to make of like to sort of Canadian,
Chris Tucker and Bruce,
whoa.
Canadians.
Totally sort of like in an intellectual,
like,
like smart guys who ended up going to the Philippines.
And just getting sucked into this abyss of like of,
of,
you know,
the reason why we're talking about shit.
If you need a location Scout,
I'm down the Philippines.
This is like one of the best spots in the world.
If you're a pool player,
there's like so many high level pool players in the Philippines,
like some of the greatest pool players of all times come out of the Philippines.
Apparently I don't want to play pool.
That's after the war.
The uh,
there's a lot of American Gis that were stationed in the Philippines and that
apparently this is what I first started the billiards craze.
I may or may not be correct about this.
Um,
but they're like this guy named effort.
Ray is like one of the top three pool players of all time.
He's a Filipino and there's like a whole bunch of Filipinos like Francisco
Bustamante Day and just like a million of them.
Like literally like there's so many like suit as far as like one small country
and what the numbers of like high level professional pool player,
the Philippines is like top to all the countries in the world.
It's incredible stories.
See a pool store.
It's a snicker story.
Snuck her being I believe harder than full but it's uh,
the most successful.
Here's well discipline you on that is it?
It's very hard.
No doubt about it.
But it's a little different.
He might've played pool to the best pool players I think stand up to the best
sneaker players ever hear about this guy.
I'm going to ask you,
cause I might've been pulled to,
I think it might've been pool.
He was a snooker champion then it pool champion.
Which guy?
He's a is an English dude.
Big Fat guy and he drank 40 pints of beer a day.
Oh Tony.
A what the fuck's because he had a thing and he could take the pill but he
couldn't play pool or it could drink 40 pints in and he was the real world.
I believe he is a world pool champion for like two or three years.
He was a sneaker guy but he won the pool but he had to drink 40 beers a day
cause he had a murmur and his arm.
I don't know,
but I love that shit.
You're five feet two but you're going to be like,
you know the,
the the best basketball player.
You have a fucking thing where your arm doesn't move but you're going to be
ranking can full player,
but if you drank enough you can do it ever.
Yeah.
Control over a spastic arm.
I don't know who that is.
Let me look that up.
There's so many 40 pints a day.
Pool player,
piano
and from where?
From?
He's from the UK.
Yeah.
There's a lot of snooker players that wind up doing really well in pool because
they have really good fundamentals because it's smaller pocket.
It's really difficult to pot what they call pot laws.
Yeah,
it's a bigger table.
Smaller pockets.
It's a very,
very,
very difficult game.
But it's a different game.
Bigger cue ball and moving,
moving the cue ball around for position ball.
The ball is slightly
bill where that's the guy.
What did he win though?
Did He,
was he pulled champion too or just he wasn't best dressed dork.
January,
through 2003 he was Canadian professionals snicker in pool player.
A recognizable for his girth.
He nicknamed big bill.
How do you know this was the guy?
Because when I googled what,
like the 40 pounds a day here,
alcohol consumption,
what does it say?
I can't read it.
Uh,
he was noted for he up to 30 pints of lager per day city that he generally drink
around six pints of lager before match.
And then one pint for each frame.
He said he did it to contract that familiar benign tumor that he had is oh wow.
He had a tumor later in his career.
He also took up pro Pollino a better blocker to cope with the effects of the
idea he ever did he ever,
uh,
when the Pool Championship?
Um,
yeah,
I think it was pool and snooker.
Hmm.
There's a lot of those guys that come out yet rolled snicker championship four
times.
All right,
here's a bunch of snuck her champions that have become really good at pool.
They started doing really well and like the uh,
Mosconi Cup and they started doing really well on the pro tour.
I know a few guys have woman,
Darrin Appleton who's a sneaker champion.
He and he played English eight ball too.
He won the uh,
what's English?
And it's just different,
different styles of April.
What happened eight ball after the color of money.
No pool band.
Pool is,
people don't play it.
It's too hard.
Video Games are easier.
You know,
it's easier to run out in a video game.
And when you,
when you're playing,
especially if you're gambling or you're playing in a tournament,
when you're playing pool,
it's really difficult to hold your nerves together.
Shot to shot.
And it's very challenging.
It's very challenging mentally.
And why was he ball so big?
Well,
eight balls because you have more options and people got that suck.
They liked it as a whole bunch of balls all over the place and they can pick
anyone they want to shoot at.
Right.
That's initially,
but April's a very strategic game because when you deal with 15 balls supposed
tonight,
how many people want to slice the rest right now and jump off a building?
Shane Smith asked me about pool.
Yeah.
Um,
when you,
uh,
when you have like a,
a really high level player,
then it becomes interesting because then it becomes very strategic because you
have to figure out what should I choose?
Should I be choose colors a showed two stripes because one of them I,
there's a pattern and the other one,
it doesn't exist.
Right?
And so I have to figure out whether or not I can get out.
And when you're playing a high level player,
it's,
it's all about the percentages that you can clear the frame,
clear the table,
right?
It's,
that's what it's all about.
And if you watch like the best players like the and ray is and the Earl
Strickland's,
it's all about if you give them a chance to get loose then they start clearing
tables and when you start they start running out racks and hitting you with
packages are all Strickland.
You want to know how bad ass motherfucker was.
Earl struck and there was a a thing.
This guy CJ Wiley who's a very famous pool player and world champion,
real high level player himself was a promoter of this event and he got an
insurance policy on the that uh,
if anybody ever ran 10 racks in a row,
they would get $1 billion,
right?
The odds you run a 10 racks if you live a hundred lifetimes are like a hundred
to one the nobody runs 10 racks,
right?
Because if you break in front out,
even if you like you,
you can hit a guy with like a six pack.
Like the odds of you getting a shot on the one ball,
the first opening ball,
there's so small because you break when you break the ball scatter randomly,
you don't know what's happened.
So the idea that a guy could write out 10 in a row seemed impossible.
So they put a million dollar insurance policy on it where Earl Strickland's this
crazy dude from North Carolina and he does not give one 10th of one fuck.
Okay.
So he's in there and he's playing in this tournament and he knows that there's a
10 rack,
$1 million challenge.
So he starts blasting nine balls in running packages.
He's running seven a now he's making half table length combinations on the nine
bullet could,
same shit he would never do.
If you're playing for $1 million,
he's free stroking for $1 million.
Right?
And he runs a 11 racks,
not just 10 11 following in combos and just,
or just running stupid rags banking out for the cheese when it's like
unbelievable pool plan and they don't want to give him the money because there's
a definition of like running a rack.
Like if you make a combination on the nine ball,
it's like a three nine combination,
you know,
is that running the rack?
You know what,
what did you,
what did you decide?
Is it winning the game cause nine balls a game where you run one ball to the two
bald,
the three ball,
you always gotta hit the lowest number of ball on the table.
Everything is wild,
right?
And so it's a,
it's a game of packages putting packages.
The guy,
the odds of a guy putting together 10 racks is what happened.
They had to settle out of court.
They had to give him like a percentage of the cheese.
They didn't give it all to him,
but unfortunately the world,
you know,
we'll never know how crazy that is because if you've never played pool,
you don't know how insane that is.
It's like getting like 18 holes in one.
It doesn't even make sense.
Like how the fuck did he do that?
How the fuck does he run 11 racks at of row on tight tables for $1 million?
Right?
It's like people reach those weird heights.
You know those weird Cassius clay versus Cleveland,
big Cat Williams Heights.
When you watch a guy performing,
do you go Jesus Christ,
like we just hit some new level.
You can just hit some,
some new revolutions per minute.
That's never been achieved before,
but people don't understand that shit.
So they,
to me pool is like a,
it's an art form that the only people that appreciate it,
the people that do it.
So if you don't play pool,
you're not going to appreciate it.
And you think about it less people playfulness,
weightless,
not true.
Yeah.
I mean I played pool the other day,
but you did take it to another level.
You take a look to this dirty levelers no.
Well who was my,
my savior.
My,
my bridge between getting injured in martial arts and then becoming a standup
comedian and pool was my bridge cause I tore my ACL and uh,
I was still
like,
uh,
I was still competing.
And then when I tore my ACL I had like a six month downtime or had to do rehab
and all that jazz.
And that was the time that I got addicted to pool.
It was during my rehab cause I can still walk around,
I go play pool.
It wasn't a stress on my knee.
And I became fascinated with his fucking name,
but it's not easy to do.
And so I went from this,
this incredibly psychotic connection to martial arts,
to this incredibly psychotic connection to that.
So it became like a way for me to get out all of these ideas that I have in my
head about like about like competing against things and about like knocking in
things and controlling things.
It's like a vehicle,
you know,
again,
like anything else has you see if we see bad ass badminton players,
he was like,
some dude told me to check out high level badminton online.
I'm like,
what?
And he's like,
you'd be surprised.
Like there's all these fakes and all these different movements.
I'm like,
okay,
yes.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Right?
But if you don't know if you,
I bet if you play badminton,
you're like God damn bad mittens,
the shifts.
But if I asked you,
Hey Shane Smith,
would you like to play badminton with me?
You play.
Can I call you back between playing badminton but the fuck are you talking
about?
That's a dead man's game.
What are you living in?
1970.
What do you have?
Uh,
a white when,
when was the highlight of Admin in this country?
Never.
It never happened.
It's a golf game.
I mean,
it's a long game and that's some shit you do in your backyard.
When was it croquet that if you want to,
you want to do some coke?
Hey,
I'm down.
But when was it big?
I don't even know.
There was nothing.
It's like tennis.
It's kind of tenants.
But with your ball.
Who is this guy and why is he holding up 10 fingers?
He started getting me out of here.
What do you got next?
What do you have to,
what do you,
where are you going next?
Uh,
I have to go have a business dinner.
What Times that we probably missed it,
I think.
How dare you?
Oh no shit.
It's only 4:00 PM in Hawaii,
right?
It's seven.
I thought it was like,
I would've said it was two in the morning.
It should be Jack Daniels.
This is,
she should be,
she should never bring those.
These other people don't bring them anymore.
They probably,
they cause problems.
They want to control things.
Hold up.
Fingers tell you about schedules.
This is all nonsense.
You done mushrooms.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't fucking bullshit me here.
Okay?
It's 10 fingers are nonsense.
This,
this is eternity right here.
okay?
This is encrypted.
Someday this would be the projected on a cave wall.
I would like them with the day Shane Smith,
Trump science.
It would be,
it would make day.
We all figured it out the day we realized that.
We're like a couple of years away from getting their shit together.
I hope so.
Do you are you will be out of business bro.
We didn't do,
we didn't know it and write stories about nice things.
Flowers and shit.
Blow jobs,
flowers and little Jon.
I'm handjobs and ice cream.
How to give the best hand with a flower and I had to go gluten free.
Sure.
All those things.
Is that the future?
What does that,
why did you have play in elephant?
Okay.
There's sometimes you have ideas in your head and what you need to do is you
need to count to 10 and at the end of that 10 if you have any doubt whatsoever
that this is a good idea.
Don't do it.
Okay.
That's my advice to you.
I like to work with restrictions.
I like to work with La,
a little land mines and roadblocks and that's what he's here for.
Okay.
Keeps me on my toes.
I know it doesn't make sense to most people,
but I think I have to a plasma just dealing with it.
Dealing with the best I can.
How has it been?
How's it been?
Stopped with the sound effects.
Who is the Adam Carolla show?
Oh shit though.
He did no [inaudible] Fox type shit.
I have hair.
Okay.
Just joking around.
Um,
how's HBO but gone?
You can join it.
Yeah,
they're nice.
I really liked the show man.
Look man,
by the way,
on demand.
Oh cool.
Hbo Is Greatest.
They have the greatest,
the two greatest in the history of humanity.
The Co two greatest shows ever.
Well,
the Sopranos and game of Thrones,
there's no second.
That's it.
There's not even a deadwood.
How dare you dare you wire the wire is really good.
But
I never watched more than two episodes of the wire and I did enjoy it,
but I never got into it but dead.
What else?
Like I don't believe they swore that much.
Oh yeah,
I loved that.
Game of Thrones is awesome.
His premise is awesome.
Those are the two best,
in my opinion,
my two favorite all time.
But I gotta be honest.
It sounds crazy,
but that fucking showtime show the terrorist guy.
But what does that show?
A home homeland.
Homeland.
That is right fucking up there.
Right fucking up there and walking dead is and isn't.
There's episodes of the walking dead you like,
is this the $6 million man?
And I go back and fucking time and my watching Steve Austin fight and bigfoot,
this shit is retarded.
There's this episodes of the walking dad would be like,
who wrote this one?
Find him,
tell him to stop,
tell him to stop.
Whose idea was this?
How did this happen?
But then there's other ones.
If you just had to watch a show game of Thrones.
Yeah,
me too.
No,
not even close.
To me,
they're making,
they're making a,
what is it,
the woman from Gilmore girls,
Lord and his radio.
They're doing lord of the rings every week.
They're literally doing it.
Lord.
Something's better.
Better than Lord of the rings.
Because the thing about Lord of the Rings,
and I'm a,
by the way,
I should state this.
I'm a huge dog and our token Dork,
that's the name or what the fuck is his name?
Jr Jr Tolkien.
I know I had it wrong.
So you're not the Hobbit,
Lord of the rings.
I read them all when I was a young boy and I remember them being like,
you know,
amazing,
like just escapes from life.
And it was a huge fan of their work.
But the problem is that these books are incredibly long.
And to condense them into a movie and keep the subtle nuances story,
like one of the beautiful things was like the,
the struggle of Bilbo Baggins carrying this ring and the whole day.
There's so much,
there's so much to it and the hundreds and hundreds of pages that to try to
condense that to a movie,
you're gonna,
you're gonna mess a lot of what made it cool.
Yeah.
So that's why the hobbit was to me a little bit.
I mean,
I had to see it.
It's my duty as a fan to see it,
but it was like,
and then this happens and then that happens.
Like I don't,
I don't feel invested.
I don't feel,
it's like,
I feel like you're rushing this whole idea and I'm not,
I'm not connecting,
but game of Thrones or like,
here are the fucking dragon and there's some shit coming down from the fucking
Antarctica and they go gangster as all humanly possible.
They make the soprano's looked like sesame street.
Well,
red wedding was God damn.
Don't say anymore.
It's,
wow are a spoiler alert.
It's just an amazing show.
And I think that that's one of the cool downsides to a or cool upsides to the
downside of the film industry is that it's harder and harder for the film
industry to try to.
What does that badminton,
that men,
it's a dead man's game.
It's harder and harder for the film industry.
It's harder for people with original ideas to get the mail.
Hold on,
hold on.
Did that just happen?
Yeah.
Somebody made that online as we were saying falling.
It's not like,
yeah,
you'd not respect me if that was like one of my standard lines.
He no dog have been talk about badminton.
Been talking shit on badminton since way back.
But do we find out the golden age of bed?
No,
we never did.
It never happened.
Just there was an idea.
But the pros like they are really pat ass.
If he watched like really high level ping pong guys,
he'll be fucking impress upon.
It's crazy.
How far did they get away from the table?
Like I get really far away.
Pink Pong guys have to cause that shit is coming and crazy and you gotta be able
to dart in and dart out.
You've got to have these explosive fast twitch muscle fibers and a lot of tech
that Howard Howard Cosell of the cause.
You're like now calling the greatest ping pong game I've ever heard.
Yeah,
I'm a retard.
That's what it is.
Why don't you plug into the,
I don't like other sports.
I would call,
come on professional.
I said to you,
America versus China Ping Pong Championship came down and get bored.
Fuck off.
I don't have enough things.
There's too many things that I'm obsessed with already.
The last thing I want to do,
it was such a ping pong North America versus North Korea for I would war war,
but they have to play a game of ping pong.
Whoever wins,
you have to call it.
What do you do it?
Yes,
sure.
Think I'm a patriot.
I would do that.
I think that would be interesting,
but that would,
that would be like full on running man.
I wouldn't go though this.
I don't know.
It's fucking wouldn't go well.
They'll probably pay more attention to bad men and they're closer to death.
So probably be real problematic here.
Going back to what material?
Yeah,
I've been doing some old shit.
I was,
he putting them back on the um,
badminton,
all those games that are like really old that had been around for a long time.
Polo and shit.
Like how much longer can polo keep going at a certain point in time?
I'm going to run out of Rachel.
You know the weird thing about it is they don't actually play Polo.
They don't know what do they do?
What if my,
what happens?
They hired a dude,
this is the whole thing.
I was like,
cause uh,
we were,
you know,
Coachella is on the Polo grounds,
right?
So we went out early to film this thing and they're like,
oh,
there's Paulo here and it's all these Argentinian ringers and Uruguayan ringers
that the guys filled their teams with the pay,
like I don't know,
hundreds of thousands of dollars to have the team.
And then they,
but they don't play themselves.
They hire a young buck to go out and play and you're like,
wow,
what are you doing?
So they hired a guy like a wild dude to ride their horse and whack their ball.
Yeah.
There you go.
So they,
they're,
they're essentially,
they're the people that own horses and team.
So they have someone represent them individually.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a sport of ringers.
It sounds like doosh doosh central,
the word duty.
She has people that are like,
how many,
how many more years can polo keep going?
Yeah.
Like if he like found out dude was like super into
Paula,
I don't think it,
I don't think it can keep going.
And you know,
it comes from by cash or whatever,
which is what the guys had or
really?
Yeah.
Well that makes it way better.
Or also they now they deal with a,
like a sheep,
a sheep pen or a sheep and actual,
she'd have to like pull the sheep through the field.
Wow.
With like hooks or something.
Like how do you hook up with your hand,
reach out and grab it and the horse runs?
Yeah.
And then the other people tried to get the sheet.
It's like,
it looks like Paulo,
but with the sheep,
those people needed the Internet.
But that's where Polo came from.
The Internet.
But I answer to your question,
I don't think it lasts much longer.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those,
those old school sports that you like,
come on son.
The decathlon.
Really,
really Bruce Jenner.
What else do we got?
What's in the old,
the oldest support leave.
Fuck.
How about curling that shit they do in Canada.
You guys push those weird looking hockey pucks across the ice.
Brooms.
Yeah.
And they sweep the,
sweep the ice to get it nice and clean.
So the,
the thing really slides.
Yeah.
Hi Larry.
This,
I don't know what you're even talking about.
It's one of the most hilarious sports of all time watching that you're like,
God damn the best.
What are these?
These people living up here where it's cold as fuck.
They're like,
it's gotta be more cool shit.
We can do it in the cold.
I like
Canadians,
political systems and I agree,
but when
you start fucking with curling,
I'm like,
fuck you.
Curling is awesome.
They're like,
let's slide smooth rocks.
That should be way better than like animated movies are interesting books.
Oh yeah.
How did that become like a big sport and get so big that it became in the
Olympics?
Because curling is in the Olympics.
I don't know.
That's pretty insane.
Yeah.
How old?
Who else does it?
It's like Canadians and who else?
We always win.
Who else is doing it?
You're winning one of the craziest game
[inaudible] of all time.
Maybe Finland,
Finland.
Fuck Finland,
man.
I do that.
I don't really mean that.
I said,
tell him I finished friends.
I don't really mean that.
I'm just bullshit.
I would've said Fuck Denmark if he said Denmark.
I don't mean that either.
Are they good at it?
They're good at it.
Then rocky is good.
It's a handle.
It's got a handle on a fucking,
I don't even know what's happened now.
The problem is is there was this one drunk podcast went south.
No,
it was perfect.
It didn't go sign.
Now
we're talking about Denmark and correct people.
We love him with Joe.
Fuck America.
Fuck Canada.
I don't mean anything was saying.
We're just talking shit.
This is called talking shit.
If you love me,
I can talk shit about you.
You can talk shit about me
when I'm being serious.
We don't really need fuck Denmark.
I'm,
I have no animosity at Denmark.
See Jokes.
They're not even good jokes.
We just swinging their folks trying to make you happy.
Okay.
No one's trying to hurt anybody's feelings,
especially not strange.
People from some frozen country filled with Douche bags.
I'm just kidding.
I made that part up.
Smells like queefs whole place to sit.
You just made that up.
He made that up.
I don't even support him.
I don't think it smells like he's never been there.
You know when,
if a pussy smells like fish,
that means there's old come inside of it.
Allegedly.
Yeah.
No,
I just mean she's got a fishing or pussy.
You don't know shit.
Then with that girl,
you have a fight about this.
The last time I was here,
I highly doubt that.
I think we did.
We had a fight sperms,
sperms.
It goes for the egg and one.
Oh yeah.
You're like,
oh,
hell no,
no,
no.
It was actually no sperm fighting other sperm.
It was unfortunately disapproved because it's a beautiful theory.
The idea that there's some sperm that serve the only purpose they serve as to
kill off fighting.
I'm fighting.
That's not true.
Apparently it was a one guy wrote a book.
Let's,
let's look at it.
It's been pretty much,
I've got to say,
I don't want it to be disproved.
I don't want it to be disproven either.
That's the problem.
I'll deal with this new shell I'm doing.
There's a lot of shit that gets disproven that I don't really want to be
disproven.
God Damn it.
Really good for you though.
I don't know if it was you,
but I,
I told
somebody,
I said,
there's two types of sperm.
One that goes for the egg and one that fights he was from and they said,
no,
that's not true,
but the penis is shaped like a
to scoop out the sperm that's in there.
Really?
Yes.
That is true.
That is absolutely true.
I was about to say,
if you're saying that there's not two types of sprint,
but yeah,
the plunger Shit's true.
The shamans apps environment,
we not screwing with the plunger,
but the two types is from not right.
Are you talking about Dolphin comic?
Can't remember.
Was it kind of Shit I was covered in dog.
Yeah.
You know that.
I'm,
you know,
God damn well I was covered in dolphin come.
I told,
I actually touched a dolphin's vagina on my showrooms at Sera.
That's frowned upon.
Well,
no,
we were allowed to touch it and I didn't know that the vagina was shut like it.
Like you can't see it when it's shut.
It's just a line.
And so I was just like,
oh,
that would hold up
court except for the fact you talked about it before you went down there.
Fuck you.
Craver dolphin creeper.
He doesn't even remember what he talked about.
Like if they want to take him to court for a deadline of a dolphin,
they would say we would like to take you back to the AP
for all 2011 pots.
You indeed say I wanted to do,
let's being inside their assholes.
Oh my God,
I can't remember that.
I think that was uploaded a new tube for your honor play time.
I bought the Kodak picture CD so they wouldn't have it.
So the principle behind this guy's idea of sperm wars is that somehow under
their sperm are competing for them,
you know,
for dominant again,
and at some sperm were sent into a kilo the sperm,
but according to most interpretations of the Work Online,
what they're saying is that this is really like shitty research and that they,
they can't really prove that sperm serve any other function other than
penetrating the egg.
And then some sperm just died.
And like it's just bad research.
Rarely.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's never,
they haven't shown here is a perfect one.
No evidence for a killer sperm or other selective interactions between human
spirit Zoma and in Spermatozoa in ejaculates of different males in vitro.
So there's no evidence of,
uh,
them actually trying to kill each other inside there,
which makes sense.
Like,
how could sperm be so complex that can not only impregnate someone,
which is incredibly complex like conveyors of a genome.
Right.
And then also they can kill like,
come on.
You got to say it's good idea.
Yeah.
It's a good idea like for to write a book,
but it doesn't make sense.
But neither does anything.
He's his eyesight.
How does,
how does deal ability to smell farts?
How does that make sense?
You can't see him smell.
This doesn't make sense.
How can you hear something?
It's not even there.
Like what is it you're hearing?
What does it mean?
I'm not sure.
It doesn't make sense,
but it's real hearing things.
The idea that you can tell in what direction you just drag that Jack Daniels
bottle across the table.
I could tell by my hearing that doesn't make sense.
Nothing makes sense.
Am I right?
Right.
Big bottle.
How much talking shit could be both,
but I don't think this killer sperm thing is real.
You,
when you were in this round Moriarty,
I wish it was true.
I believe in it
more than big foot.
Do you believe in it more than Scientology?
Uh,
no.
Santana,
Jay,
he's legit.
If you have money,
you can buy rankings and some fake church thing.
You don't believe in big foot or Raul.
Hmm.
You don't believe in big trouble?
No,
I don't believe in big foot.
That's the dumbest shit ever.
I mean Lik look at Charlie Sheen with his little Naknek lochness monster shit.
Yeah.
He just went down to go find the lochness monster.
Guess why he didn't find it?
Yeah.
They must have good crack at the bottom of the ocean looking for,
you know,
it sounds cooler.
I believe that there is that Godzilla that sounds cooler hides behind the island
or something.
That makes sense.
Pride go slip.
No.
Like that makes more sense than fucking big than bigfoot.
Why does that make less sentence?
Why?
Yeah.
Tell me just as a complete outsider,
because like it's been already been half the big old,
big foot,
uh,
like videos and stuff.
I've already been disproven that it's been just hoaxes,
you know?
And it's just,
everyone's just trying to make this bullshit thing be real when it really,
it's just a bunch of hoaxes.
Well,
there's definitely a lot of hoax.
I mean,
yeah,
there might be a monkey that lives in the woods,
but that's not the big foot that everyone else is talking about.
And when I was just talking about all these hoaxes,
so like to believe and then put to those two things together,
it's just,
it's just like,
all right,
move on.
Let's worry about something else that's real like aids.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
like I'm doing this show that I've been doing and actually go in and looking for
bigfoot.
I hear you 100% but I also go,
the weirdest thing about looking for bigfoot is I went into it semi seriously.
I went into it for the sci fi show and my idea was that,
you know what,
man,
I really would like for bigfoot to be real.
Jane Goodall says,
Big Foot's real.
I mean,
she really believes she believes 100% she's absolutely sure there's an
undiscovered primate said by the uniformity of the sightings,
by the fact that gigantic Pythagoras was a real animal that mimic the size,
shape,
the fact that it was by bipedal.
It lived as recently as a hundred thousand years ago,
and this is just the bones that they found.
They didn't even find those bones.
So the 1920 so it leaves a giant window of possibility.
Then you'd go there and I'm telling you,
man,
you go to the Pacific northwest and you walk around,
you go,
oh,
no one knows what's up here.
I mean,
you get out there.
We went to mount Rainier and we went into the woods.
You just take a road into the woods.
It's a dirt road.
You go a couple miles down,
and that's what we started to make camp.
And you go off into the woods from there,
you're in another dimension.
You're going to God damn avatar movie.
I mean,
and it goes on for thousands and thousands of square miles.
I bet there's a lot of people walking those woods.
Hi.
And
I'm telling you,
the d,
The penetration by human beings is extremely limited.
You'd have to go there to understand it.
I joked around about it before we actually went there,
but once I,
once I was actually there and Duncan and I went wandering through the woods,
we were like,
oh,
well nobody knows what the fuck is up here.
Like literally you,
we sent these drones with cameras above the woods to get a view and you're
talking about just an insane like to the horizon as far as you can see and no
one's there.
It's just dense trees like a box of Q tips.
It sounds so silly that there's a crazy monkey living in the woods.
It sounds so silly,
but the reality is no one knows what the fuck is out there.
So why again,
you like chimps and gorillas so much and no,
sorry.
Hate them so much,
but love.
I know I don't,
I don't hate any of them.
I don't hate the champion.
I'm freaked out by our freight terrify them,
but obsessed with big foot and Werewolf's.
Well,
it's also,
I know that human beings are dangerous.
I know,
I know a lot of dangerous human beings.
Physically dangerous,
mentally dangerous.
There's human beings can be very dangerous.
So the potential for destruction and trying to manage and mitigate that,
it's fascinating to me.
And then you see something that takes it to a complete different level,
like a gorilla.
And how about Sasquatch?
Well,
but this was what I was going to say.
One of the fascinating things is about,
they're obviously not as smart as us.
So,
and what are they get instead?
Well,
they get the ability to swing from branch to branch and fly from tree to tree.
That's what a chimp cats.
What does it gorilla get?
Well,
he gets to lie on the ground cause he doesn't give a fuck.
He's not worried about Jaguars.
Jaguars best step the fuck away from a gorilla.
Nobody wants to fuck with a gorilla.
Lions don't want to fuck with the gorilla.
Elephants don't want to fuck with the gorilla.
They look at it and they go,
oh Jesus Christ,
let's just go over here.
That's what they do.
So I think there's that.
You know,
there's the,
the,
there's this idea that there's this weird sort of balanced to the world and
these dumb motherfuckers heating water roots and pulling them out.
They had the strongest things I've ever lived.
If you have it like a gorilla football team,
that could,
that fucking team would be undefeated throughout human history.
Sasquatch.
I love all of it.
I'm,
look,
I'm fascinated by everything.
They can kill me.
Everything that's dangerous.
Everything that's,
that's wild.
Cause I think that we're too used to these things.
We just accept the fact I went to the zoo recently.
I was in Colorado like this entry or limes tick.
I'm scared of all that shit to Lyme disease is terrifying,
man.
I tweeted something about Lyme disease recently.
Lyme disease is fairly recent.
It's only been the last few decades that people have either been diagnosed by
this or contracted this.
But Lyme disease is terrifying and it's also been connected to more Jelonese.
No more gel is this crazy disease where you have these fibers growing out of
your party.
It's been connected to hyperkeratinization but that's what's,
that's what's terrifying to me is that shit.
Yeah,
it's horrifying.
Well,
the flu is hard.
This is all stuff that we're covering on,
on my new show too.
There's a,
there's a whole episode on diseases and the idea of these,
these,
these are 28 days later type scenarios,
right?
How possible is it is bioterrorism,
I own martyrs.
The idea that someone can,
you know,
give someone a disease and send him on a plane if these are all things that are
being considered like I am not in any way shape or form in support of the
government of being able to read your emails.
If you read the whole thing is just Douche tastic but if you really thought
there was some 28 days later shit coming or the potential of stopping it was
only achieved through monitoring everything,
you know,
you'd be interested in doing it.
Sure.
I just think that the problem is,
is you,
the result is the sort of bureaucrats with just what I'm going to call amounts
of power.
Of course,
of course,
and it's always been a problem.
At some point you have to say whether it has to be some sort of privacy,
there has to be some sort of democracy.
There has to be some sort of something and and and sure like they should get
better at,
at,
at data gathering,
but they shouldn't watch all of our shit all the time.
It's also like who's who
gets to do this?
Like are these regular people?
I think the most moral of,
of all of us,
if they've been proven to be the most qualified to sort of dispense knowledge.
I have a gambling that August,
go talk to this guy because I know everything about this shit.
Yeah,
it might be that.
I need 20 grand dude.
I bet
people are people they're going to do shit but,
but some people know everything about other people.
But I think that I,
I'm,
I'm certainly not in favor of all this happening,
but what I,
what I am and what I am excited about is the debate.
I'm excited about the debate of information distribution of information and the
discussion on possibilities of controlling it and if there are even viable
because that becomes a real,
I think that becomes a real question.
So what do you think of Snowden?
I don't know.
I have these Wa I,
my idea is very wildly and none of 'em are substantial like substantiate double
whatever that word is.
You can't,
you can't.
Um,
I I think you can't really make an accurate prognosis.
I think there's a lot of people that are viewing what this exponential course of
technology's going to take us
but also one directly like Wiki,
wiki leaks versus non wiki leaks.
So,
so they leaked it and we know but it's weakening us but they leaked it and we
know more.
And actually it started this whole nother thing.
I'm going to take it to a even crazier level.
I think bunny itself,
it's going to be invalid.
I think we're going to reach a point in time where information is so freely
distributed that money is essentially information at this point.
Ones and Zeros accumulated on hard drives and databases.
They don't really mean anything anymore.
We're not,
it's not like $1 as well.
One paper note is one pound of gold.
It doesn't mean that anymore.
Right?
So you're in this weird stage where everything is digital and the trend seems to
be,
at least to me,
to the uneducated trying to follow the trend seems to be for a dissolving of all
the barriers between people and information.
And if money becomes information,
which is what it is,
it's just ones and Zeros.
How are you going to stop people from controlling and may be dispensing that
one,
those ones and Zeros.
And if something comes along during that process of,
of,
of confusion,
of integration,
if something comes along that sorta redistributes people's competitive edges and
turns him into a social thing and it says,
listen,
the money thing,
what we're going to do with the bunny thing,
let's just like sort of evenly spread it out.
Like that's a real possibility.
And what do you think of Bitcoin then?
Um,
I don't know too much about it.
I don't know about how secure it is,
how much it can be manipulated.
I wonder if idealistic people who get involved in some sort of a counterculture
currency,
how much,
how much can that currency be manipulated by someone who truly understands
finances?
How much of it can be just a new pawn in a new game that we fuck up and we hack
the new PAC man so it's like shut it down.
Yeah.
Well could be that too.
They could sabotage it.
They can tank it.
There's a lot of weirdness to any sort of a new currency.
But it's exciting that someone's willing to entertain the possibility for sure.
You know?
But it's scary too because the people that are in control of this world and not
going to let go lightly,
that's the problem.
That's why we need to get them.
She didn't trust Xbox live currency more than a bitcoin.
You know,
like I really trust it more than I can do to keep my money.
Xbox live points.
Yeah.
The big coin is like,
man,
where's that going to go?
I don't know.
I hold,
the problem with it is that it's,
you know,
obviously an alternative currency.
So people are using it for different shit.
And they're saying,
well,
how long until they shut them down.
But they're saying,
well,
we're going to operate in such a way that you can't shut us down.
Well,
it's,
it's very interesting.
Anything that happens on the Internet where,
you know,
you go all anonymousy,
he'd go all free ball and you go out there bitcoin,
you know,
he just,
he realized that these people are coalescing and they have these ideas and make
your plans,
okay,
here's a new currency.
Oh boy,
what happens now?
What is it doing?
When is someone going to just say,
hey,
let's all meet in Sweden.
We got to a spot.
It's thousand acres.
Let's start building houses.
I mean,
that's like,
that's one of those things.
So I think has happened throughout human history.
There's this,
the reason why America exists and these people that are like so pro-america but
anti change have to understand there's only one reason why this spot is
populated by white people.
That's because England sucked.
It was fucking terrible.
It was a mess.
And it had gotten to this breaking point where people are like,
we gotta get the fuck out.
We got to risk our lives to get on a boat.
We have to get through the ocean and survive plague.
We have to get over there.
This is not going to work anymore.
And that that's a trend that created,
in my opinion,
is the greatest nation the world has ever known and that trend needs to continue
and it doesn't mean it's bad for the people in power.
It just means they have to understand that growth has to be achieved and we have
to move on.
And when things are illuminated that show very clearly that there's an equities
and things were all wrong,
they have to be corrected.
You can still make money.
Everybody can make money,
just cut the shit.
And you know,
you got to understand what's moral and what's ethical and what's not.
And when things become really transparent,
you can't get away with just fucking putting bulletproof vests on people and
sending them out with guns.
You've got to come up with the answers.
You got to,
you got to tell people,
yeah,
I know word control,
but we're trying to evolve as well.
We're growing as well.
We're human beings as well.
We've made mistakes.
We're on a bad path.
We've been following the momentum of Barbera's people from the beginning of time
to today,
and maybe we didn't realize the repercussions of our actions.
The fact that we would perhaps be even happier if we didn't engage in them,
and then slowly the dust settles.
That's the rosy picture.
That's the rosy picture of humanity is the crazy monkeys meet in the middle of
the street and he'd go,
all right,
we don't need to do this anymore.
Right?
Okay,
how do I don't want,
this is not making me happy.
Find another fucking outlet.
Finding an outlet for that.
All those assholes that are out there blowing up the world,
they need you Jitsu in their lives.
They need to go around Shogun people,
you know,
they need to take a [inaudible] class,
get their ass kicked,
stop trying to dominate the planet.
That's just ridiculous.
Can't let some preaching right there.
If I wasn't me,
I'd download this podcast and deleted immediately.
I certain point in time,
we all know this.
I know you notice somebody doesn't know that though.
That's the problem.
Sure if they did know it and it's not happening at a certain point in time when
you say things that you would like to happen,
but they don't have,
when people go,
we focused on with your utopian bullshit.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
I think it's a bad idea to be nice to each other.
They don't think it's a bad idea to figure out a better way to control the
resources of the world.
That's because,
you know,
you grow up,
you're older and you're like,
you know,
let's not just fight.
Let's just,
hey,
but could you imagine,
can you imagine if you were the head of like,
you know,
some gigantic oil company or some huge bank and you're just making just on godly
sums of cash.
Like you're strapped onto a roller coaster and you're flying down through a
river of million dollar bills just covering you constantly.
You're absorbing money every second of the day.
Just constantly buying Mercedes and Bentleys and private jets and getting your
Dick sucked and it's almost entirely intoxicating and impossible to get off that
ride.
Is that right?
It's so fun.
Have no one,
no one questions you.
You're walking around,
you have a million butlers and you just tell everybody what the fuck to do and
getting your jet and you fly to Paris and you do whatever you want.
That's,
that's,
that's
the people that have the most money in this world.
That's where they're at.
They're at this ridiculous position where no one should have ever let them get
to the point where they can have a boat that's 700 feet long.
Like what happened?
They're like,
what did you do?
You move numbers around.
That's how you got a boat.
Did you even sell anything?
Hold on.
Oh,
who's making the most out of it?
But it's a lot like India where you said earlier on the show,
like there's a a billion and a half dollar house coming out of a slum.
Why aren't they fucking say no,
no,
we'll be taking this now.
This will be our shit.
And it's the same thing here.
It's like,
okay,
you know,
as a guy who does a hedge fund,
who's hedging against the economy,
who has a 400 foot yacht,
okay,
I know it's credit against us.
Well,
he figured out a way to manipulate the system and extract money in some weird
way.
It's legal,
you know,
and he's allowed to like be a baller.
I mean the guy in India,
how did he make all that money?
What does he doing?
But I certainly think that the Indian way of dealing with it is more appealing
for sure.
I will just go,
oh,
that's what he did.
You know?
I don't think the,
the way to do it is to write it up every time someone has more than you to try
to steal their Robin with their shit.
Yeah.
That doesn't work either.
It doesn't work.
What does work,
Shane Smith and all the years you've seen on advice,
what do you think works the best system in this country and this world rather
I in Canada?
No,
I mean anywhere where you make a lot of money,
it's going to be okay.
That's the best system.
Yeah.
Like,
if you go to Switzerland,
everything's great and works and is clean and nice and Germany,
toilets and stuff.
Yeah.
But Switzerland in particular because it's small and it's rich.
So like if you go to a toilet there,
it's awesome.
If you go to like,
you know,
and you know,
I need something and whatever,
that's awesome.
Health care or whatever,
but you know,
it's smaller than rich.
That's the thing is smaller,
which is good.
Yeah.
Well if you're gonna,
if you're going to pay,
you know,
for,
for those things,
for public benefit,
it has to be rich.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
so you think like European countries like Switzerland,
like,
oh,
well,
I mean,
I mean what I'm saying is this,
those countries are like where you see something that works like it works
because it costs a lot of money to make it work.
And if you,
when it doesn't work,
when you go to countries that don't have a lot of money,
the system doesn't work because it breaks down.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's an also a debate in this country about how difficult it is getting to
Canada.
And I've talked to my friends about this and I'm like,
I think it's good if you're running a great country like Canada,
you would you want people to come in that have had it was a lot easier in Canada
than in America.
Is that I think,
I don't know because I only know one way,
but I know that a candidate won't let you in if you have a Dui.
I have friends that have a Dui.
They can't get into Canada.
That's the same with states,
is it?
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Any criminal record you can't think that makes sense.
So they're fairly equal,
but so smaller,
richer countries where where?
Where like Switzerland,
where they get their money from felt bank to make knives to me.
Cool night training,
make good cheese.
Whether they do it for money,
they make an all right.
What is a swindlers?
Okay,
we're going to move,
wrap the site.
I don't think you guys have to get you out of here.
Do you have something else to do?
You do something else tonight.
Sorry.
Yeah.
How are they going to deal with the fact that you're all fucked up?
Uh,
they're used to it.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
I'm like,
yeah,
I gotta go,
you know,
see my buddy.
And they're like,
what are you doing?
Really?
And I'm like,
wow.
I have a friend.
Like,
you know,
I'm going to do,
oh,
I'm going to do Rogan.
And they're like,
oh,
you're not coming.
You're not going to make it.
You're gonna make it.
You're not gonna,
everything's gonna be fine.
People need you to relax.
But these silly things around our wrists,
okay,
these are just a suggestion.
A certain time and place when you get to a certain age,
if you really still have to listen to that,
you've made a mistake.
Okay.
At a certain point in time,
unless she's catching a flight,
those fucking things and they help you guy guy,
he got better.
They got people that have them.
That's even more baller than actually having a watch.
You have another dude who wears the watch.
You're like,
I don't want to be burdened by metal.
That's true.
Tell me when my meeting arises so I can collect more ones and Zeros.
Watch Kenny Martin.
Yeah,
there you go.
Makes Sense.
Kids got knowledge dude.
Um,
look,
thanks man was awesome.
Whoever your friend was that we called in the last podcast and apparently I was
drunk and I said rude things to him that I didn't really mean.
It was just for the sake of comedy fellow.
Who Was it?
Matt Ruskin.
I'm so sorry.
He's a big boy.
We were lit up.
We were,
we were so lit up at the next day.
I wasn't really sure that I remembered it even happening.
Thought maybe someone was trying to suggest some shit and plant some false
memories.
One of my favorite podcasts of all time.
It was fun.
One,
it was very fun.
What number was that dude?
Just tell people if they want to download a good one of me being belligerent.
Three 38.
Powerful.
Jamie,
three 38.
Shane Smith.
You bad motherfucker.
I love you man.
I love you too buddy.
This was a lot of fun.
Always,
always fun.
Uh,
vice.com.
You freaks get your shit together and [inaudible] on HBO on demand.
We could watch it,
stream it.
Oh,
I know what I'm doing tonight.
So a sort of wrap things up.
Sprayer.
Morrows not true.
Sperm are killing sperm.
There's no sperm wars going on.
Um,
thanks to thanks to stamps.com,
use the code word jre.
Save yourself some money.
Thanks to legal zoom.
Use the code name.
Rogan,
save yourself some money there this weekend.
San Diego,
uh,
Brian Red band will be there with Tony Hinchcliffe and not attending.
Hinchcliffe Oh,
Tony Stevens here.
Sarah Tiana.
Or we got yo,
she's down there.
Benji's doubtful Yoshi.
We got some secret guests.
Uh,
we also have Mike Black in there and it's also like during comic con.
So a bunch of weird character.
Midnight shows too.
Oh,
midnight shows.
I was on the,
uh,
the earlier shows,
Brian Post saying,
oh beautiful.
So Brian by saying an early,
a death squad party late at night and it's going to be special guests.
Beautiful.
Oh Jesus.
Louise's ladies and gentlemen,
how can you go wrong?
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n,
n I,
t,
use the code name,
Rogan,
and save yourself some car.
My next gig will be with the Great Tom Segura,
and that's,
uh,
the 26th of July in Seattle at the Moore Theater.
And me and Tommy bonds will be rocking the house.
And then,
uh,
August 16th in Boston at the Wilbur theater,
boal shows are sold out.
Unfortunately,
no.
Notice how it says sold out,
so I don't even use it now.
I give no fucks.
Um,
and that's with Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir boom,
suck upon it.
And then,
uh,
the PAPP's theater in Milwaukee on the 30th of August.
All right.
We love the fuck out of you guys and we'll see you next week.
I'm going to do a podcast with Dunkin,
and while I'm on the road and a,
we're going looking for you,
fos and shit,
of course we're going to find on Holla
big kisses.
Hmm.